Is it me or do you have a good ear? Maybe it's just an impression, but the song likes to relax the sound of people who talk to you about super captivating topics for hours. It sounds good, because I have something really interesting for you. The first mobility service by subscription to the country offered by the mobile audience. Yes, of course. At Star, you can subscribe to your 5G forfeiture without being attached. Mobile audience.
是我多心了，还是你的听力很好？也许这只是我的错觉，但那首歌总是能让人在听到那些长篇大论、引人入胜的话题时感到放松。这听起来不错，因为我确实有一些非常有趣的事情要告诉你。这是移动用户提供的全国首个订阅制移动服务。是的，当然。在Star，你可以订阅你的5G套餐，而无需绑定合约。移动用户。
To you, the difference. Or on our website. Accessible only by boat and with only 2,000 permanent residents, the island spans 21 square kilometers of postcard worthy landscapes. Coconut trees are bound with the mangrove jungle giving way to pristine golden sand beaches. Imposing granite boulders jut out from the turquoise waters, which are home to coral reefs and marine life. Once a sleepy island inhabited mostly by fishermen, by 2014 Katao had become the mecca for scuba diving in Southeast Asia.
对你来说，这就是区别。或者访问我们的网站。该岛仅能乘船抵达，常住人口仅2000人，拥有21平方公里的明信片般的美景。椰子树与红树林丛林交织，通向原始的金色沙滩。雄伟的花岗岩巨石从绿松石般的海水中突起，那里是珊瑚礁和海洋生物的家园。曾经是一个主要由渔民居住的宁静小岛，到2014年，涛岛已成为东南亚的潜水圣地。
Translated in English to Turtle Island, half a million tourists flocked there each year to enjoy its natural beauty, affordable prices and laid back lifestyle. For a fraction of the cost of back home, westerners could spend their days diving, exploring or sunbathing with a cocktail in hand, before treating themselves to a Thai massage and heading out to one of the many bars that dot the shorelines. As dawn approached that Monday morning, a beach cleaner was combing the sands of Siree Beach, the main tourist hub that houses a majority of the island's bars, dive shops and accommodation. As they neared the reef outside of the ocean view bungalows, they noticed something among the rocky alcove on the shoreline. The body of a white blonde female was lying on blood-soaked sand.
翻译成英文是“海龟岛”，每年有五十万游客涌向这里，享受其自然美景、实惠的价格和悠闲的生活方式。只需在家乡花费的一小部分钱，西方人就可以整天潜水、探险或手持鸡尾酒晒太阳，然后享受泰式按摩，再前往遍布海岸线的众多酒吧之一。周一清晨黎明将至时，一名海滩清洁工正在梳理塞里海滩的沙子，这里是岛上主要的旅游中心，拥有岛上大部分的酒吧、潜水店和住宿设施。当他们靠近海景平房外的礁石时，他们注意到岸边的岩石凹处有些东西。一具白人金发女性的尸体躺在血迹斑斑的沙滩上。
In the water approximately 12 meters away was the body of a white male floating in the shallow tide. The surrounding water was red with blood. When 23-year-old Hannah Witheridge announced her plans to travel to Thailand from her home in Norfolk, England, her parents were apprehensive. They perceived the foreign country to be a dangerous place for a young woman. Sue Witheridge tried to talk her daughter out of it, urging Hannah to visit Australia or Europe instead. But Hannah's mind was made up. Her last few years had revolved around study and she was eager for a break. Having completed a degree in education at the University of East Anglia, Hannah had begun a postgraduate course in speech and language therapy.
在约12米外的水中，漂浮着一具白人男性的尸体，随着浅潮起伏。周围的水被血染红了。当23岁的汉娜·威瑟里奇宣布她计划从英国诺福克的家中前往泰国旅行时，她的父母感到担忧。他们认为这个外国对一个年轻女性来说是个危险的地方。苏·威瑟里奇试图劝阻女儿，敦促汉娜去澳大利亚或欧洲。但汉娜心意已决。她过去几年的生活围绕着学习，她渴望休息一下。在东安格利亚大学完成了教育学学位后，汉娜开始了一门言语和语言治疗的研究生课程。
She looked forward to a career centered around helping others, but she also craved some much needed downtime and adventure. So, when the possibility of visiting Thailand with a close group of her friends arose, Hannah jumped at the chance. Although she promised to contact her parents every day, they remained anxious as she began her journey through the bustling foreign country. When Hannah reached Khatau on September 12, 2014, her parents breathed the sigh of relief. They could finally relax knowing that the island posed little threat as their daughter would be doing little besides sunbathing and swimming. Hannah and her friends checked into the Ocean View bungalows on Siree Beach and no frills hotel offering basic facilities within walking distance to a selection of bars and restaurants. The foursome hadn't been there long when they met a pair of fellow British backpackers, David and Chris, who were staying in an adjacent room. Like Hannah, 24-year-old David Miller was dedicated to his studies.
她期待着一份以帮助他人为核心的职业，但她也渴望一些急需的休息时间和冒险。因此，当有机会与一群亲密的朋友去泰国旅行时，汉娜抓住了这个机会。虽然她答应每天联系父母，但当她开始穿越这个繁华的外国时，他们仍然感到焦虑。当汉娜于2014年9月12日到达涛岛时，她的父母松了一口气。他们终于可以放松了，因为知道这个岛几乎没有什么威胁，他们的女儿除了晒太阳和游泳外不会做别的事。汉娜和她的朋友们入住了塞里海滩的海景平房，这是一家提供基本设施的简朴酒店，步行即可到达多家酒吧和餐厅。这四个人到那里没多久，就遇到了另外两名英国背包客大卫和克里斯，他们住在隔壁房间。和大卫一样，24岁的大卫·米勒也专注于学业。
Having just completed a degree in civil and structural engineering at Leeds University, David left his hometown of Jersey in Britain's Channel Islands to spend six weeks undertaking a work placement at a mining company in Australia. Deciding to spend some time travelling around Southeast Asia before returning home to complete his master's degree, David ventured to Thailand with his close friend Chris Ware to meet up with some other friends on Khatau. David and Hannah and their friends quickly hit it off. On the night of Sunday, September 14, the group headed out to Choppers, a busy sports bar just off Siree Beach. As they chatted and laughed over drinks, the bar's owner snapped a photo of the young travellers to promote his venue on social media. It captured a smiling Hannah wearing a pink top with her long blonde hair flowing down while her friends pulled faces behind her. Her mobile phone and small handbag rested on the table in front of her. David sat between his friends on the other side of the table wearing a grey t-shirt with his brown hair combed to the side and a big smile on his face. Just after midnight, Hannah and her girlfriends made their way to the AC bar, a lively beachfront venue popular with experts and backpackers.
大卫刚在利兹大学完成了土木与结构工程学位，他离开家乡英国海峡群岛的泽西岛，前往澳大利亚一家矿业公司进行为期六周的实习。在回国完成硕士学位之前，大卫决定花些时间在东南亚旅行，于是他与好友克里斯·韦尔一起前往泰国，在涛岛与朋友们会合。大卫、汉娜和他们的朋友们很快就打成了一片。9月14日星期日晚上，这群人去了塞里海滩附近的繁忙运动酒吧Choppers。当他们边喝边聊、欢声笑语时，酒吧老板拍下了这些年轻游客的照片，以便在社交媒体上宣传他的店。照片中，汉娜穿着粉色上衣，留着长长的金发，笑容满面，而她的朋友们在她身后做鬼脸。她的手机和小手提包放在她面前的桌子上。大卫坐在桌子另一边朋友们中间，穿着灰色T恤，棕色头发梳向一边，脸上带着灿烂的笑容。午夜刚过，汉娜和她的女性朋友们前往了AC酒吧，这是一个深受外籍人士和背包客欢迎的热闹海滨场所。
David and Chris joined them shortly after 2am. At some point in the early hours of the morning, Hannah and David left via the bar's back entrance and walked towards their hotel into the darkness. The following morning, police were summoned to the beach outside the Ocean View bungalows. Thailand is a deeply religious country and the area where police were called was surrounded by temples. When they saw what had taken place there, the officers were shaken spiritually. The first officer who arrived on the scene later remarked, I hope God will punish the person who committed this crime. Hannah witheridge and David Miller's bodies were sprawled on the beach, both having been victims of a brutal attack.
大卫和克里斯在凌晨2点后不久加入了她们。在清晨的某个时候，汉娜和大卫从酒吧的后门离开，走向黑暗中的酒店。第二天早上，警察被传唤到海景平房外的海滩。泰国是一个宗教信仰深厚的国家，警察被叫到的地方周围环绕着寺庙。当他们看到那里发生的事情时，警官们在精神上受到了震撼。第一位到达现场的警官后来评论说：“我希望上帝能惩罚犯下这起罪行的人。”汉娜·威瑟里奇和大卫·米勒的尸体横陈在海滩上，两人都是残酷袭击的受害者。
Hannah was laying in the sand by a looming rocky wall. She had been bludgeoned numerous times with a blunt object causing her death. Deep jagged wounds were all over her face and head. Her upper and lower jaw, forehead and both eye sockets were broken. She was naked from the waist down, her white skirt pushed up over her torso. She had been raped and there were bite marks near her right nipple. David Miller was floating in the shallow water nearby, naked except for a single black sock. He had also sustained multiple head wounds.
汉娜躺在耸立的岩壁旁的沙滩上。她被钝器多次重击致死。她的脸部和头部布满了深深的锯齿状伤口。她的上下颌、前额和两个眼眶都骨折了。她腰部以下赤裸，白裙被推到躯干上方。她遭到了强奸，右乳头附近有咬痕。大卫·米勒漂浮在附近的浅水中，除了一只黑袜子外全身赤裸。他的头部也遭受了多处创伤。
His upper jaw was broken as were his eye sockets and cheekbones. Defense wounds on his hands showed that a struggle had taken place. However, water found in his lungs indicated he had been alive when he was thrown into the sea and that he had ultimately died from drowning. Hannah and David's clothing was strewn about on the blood-streaked beach with footprints pressed into the sand around them. Underneath the fallen log nearby was a blood-stained garden hoe typically used for digging beachside fire pits. The hoe belonged to a local man who had actually found it before the police and taken it back to his garden, only returning it once he realized its significance. The police also collected three L&M brand cigarette butts, a black flip-flop shoe and a used condom. The condom contained Hannah's DNA but according to police it was too contaminated to recover anyone else's.
他的上颌骨折，眼眶和颧骨也骨折了。手上的防御性伤口表明发生过挣扎。然而，肺部发现的水表明他在被扔进海里时还活着，最终死于溺水。汉娜和大卫的衣服散落在血迹斑斑的海滩上，周围的沙地上留下了脚印。附近倒下的原木下是一把沾满血迹的锄头，通常用于挖掘海滩篝火坑。这把锄头属于一名当地男子，他实际上在警察之前发现了它，并把它带回了自己的花园，直到意识到它的重要性后才归还。警方还收集了三个L&M品牌的烟头、一只黑色人字拖和一只用过的避孕套。避孕套中含有汉娜的DNA，但据警方称，它被污染得太严重，无法提取其他人的DNA。
However, semen staining on Hannah's body was viable for DNA testing. DNA was also lifted from the cigarette butts. At the time there were only six police officers stationed on Cattel and there in experience with major murder investigations quickly became evident. Firstly, they didn't put a stop to boats coming and going from the island giving the perpetrator or perpetrators the opportunity to flee. Secondly, their failure to properly secure the crime scene led to curious tourists and locals contaminating the scene as they gathered around to see what was going on. Some members of the public even took photos with their mobile phones and quickly posted them to social media. Before long, graphic images of Hannah and David's mutilated bodies were circulating online, much to the horror of the victims' loved ones who were grappling to come to terms with the news back home. Although a motive for the murders wasn't immediately obvious, police didn't think it was a random attack.
然而，汉娜尸体上的精液污渍可用于DNA检测。DNA也从烟头上提取出来。当时，涛岛上只有六名警察，他们缺乏重大谋杀案调查经验的事实很快显现出来。首先，他们没有阻止船只进出岛屿，这让肇事者有机会逃跑。其次，他们未能妥善保护犯罪现场，导致好奇的游客和当地人在聚集观看时污染了现场。一些公众甚至用手机拍照并迅速发布到社交媒体上。不久之后，汉娜和大卫被毁容尸体的血腥照片在网上流传，这让受害者在家乡的亲人们感到震惊，他们正努力接受这个消息。虽然谋杀动机并不明显，但警方认为这不是随机袭击。
Given the extent of Hannah and David's injuries, they believed it was a crime of passion sparked by jealousy or anger. They questioned David's travel companion Chris Ware who was highly distressed and unable to shed any light on the tragedy. Police were suspicious. Chris had an injury on his right hand which he insisted was the result of a prior accident. He said he and David had been due to leave Katow that day after the murders and they'd made no enemies during their time on the island. He couldn't think of any reason why someone would want to hurt David, who was widely adored by those who knew him. Likewise, Hannah's friends had no information that could help with the investigation. With no evidence to link Hannah or David's friends to the crime, police gave them permission to leave the island.
考虑到汉娜和大卫受伤的程度，他们认为这是一起由嫉妒或愤怒引发的激情犯罪。他们询问了大卫的旅伴克里斯·韦尔，他非常痛苦，无法为这场悲剧提供任何线索。警方表示怀疑。克里斯右手有伤，他坚称这是之前事故的结果。他说他和大卫本打算在谋杀案发生的那天离开涛岛，他们在岛上期间没有结下任何仇人。他想不出为什么有人会伤害大卫，大卫深受认识他的人的喜爱。同样，汉娜的朋友也没有任何可以帮助调查的信息。由于没有证据将汉娜或大卫的朋友与犯罪联系起来，警方允许他们离开该岛。
However, they soon realized this was a mistake. Forensic examination of Hannah's body revealed fragments of blonde hair in her hand. This was significant given that Chris was blonde whereas David's hair was brown. A subsequent inspection of the hotel room David and Chris had shared also revealed there was dried blood on a pair of David's pants. Police began to wonder whether David and Chris could have been involved in some kind of love triangle that went violently awry. Two days after Hannah and David's bodies were found, Chris Ware and his older brother James were stopped for further questioning at Bangkok International Airport as they attempted to leave the country. James had spent time with David and Chris on Katow but had left the island the night before the murders had occurred. Regardless, police ordered the brothers to stay in Thailand until the results of DNA testing came back.
然而，他们很快意识到这是一个错误。对汉娜尸体的法医检查显示，她手中残留着金发碎片。考虑到克里斯是金发，而大卫的头发是棕色，这一点很重要。随后对大卫和克里斯共用的酒店房间的检查也发现，大卫的一条裤子上有干涸的血迹。警方开始怀疑大卫和克里斯是否卷入了某种演变成暴力的三角恋。在汉娜和大卫的尸体被发现两天后，克里斯·韦尔和他的哥哥詹姆斯在试图离开泰国时，在曼谷国际机场被拦下接受进一步询问。詹姆斯曾在涛岛与大卫和克里斯待在一起，但在谋杀案发生的前一天晚上离开了该岛。无论如何，警方命令这对兄弟留在泰国，直到DNA检测结果出来。
News of the murders made international headlines creating a public relations nightmare for Thailand where tourism accounts for 10% of the economy. Roughly 20 million tourists visit the country each year but those numbers had recently been under threat. In May of 2014, a military coup had overthrown the democratically elected government and Thailand had since been under martial law. The political instability combined with the fact that most travel insurance companies excluded cover for destinations where martial law is in place meant the number of foreigners visiting Thailand had been decreasing. With the brutal killer or killers targeting holiday makers now on the loose, the pressure was on for authorities to make an arrest and fast. Adding to the pressure was the fact that the neighbouring island of Kop Pen Yang had developed an unsavory reputation that threatened to tarnish Katow standing as a peaceful, relaxing tourist destination. Famous for its monthly full moon parties which attracted upwards of 30,000 young revelers, Kop Pen Yang had become notorious for drugs, sexual assaults and robberies. Many locals believed the same criminals who preyed on tourists on Kop Pen Yang were taking advantage of Katow's growing party scene.
谋杀案的消息登上了国际头条，给泰国造成了公关噩梦，旅游业占该国经济的10%。每年约有2000万游客访问泰国，但这些数字最近受到了威胁。2014年5月，一场军事政变推翻了民选政府，此后泰国一直处于戒严状态。政治不稳定，加上大多数旅游保险公司将戒严地区排除在承保范围之外，意味着访问泰国的外国人数量一直在减少。随着残忍的杀手现在逍遥法外，当局面临着迅速逮捕凶手的压力。增加压力的是，邻近的帕岸岛因其臭名昭著的声誉而威胁到涛岛作为和平、放松的旅游目的地的地位。帕岸岛以其每月一次的满月派对而闻名，吸引了超过3万名年轻狂欢者，因毒品、性侵犯和抢劫而臭名昭著。许多当地人认为，在帕岸岛上掠夺游客的罪犯正在利用涛岛日益增长的派对场景。
Thailand's self-appointed Prime Minister, Army Chief General Pray Utan Orsha appeared on television to address the issue of tourist safety. Commenting, Tourists think our country is beautiful and safe so they can do whatever they want, they can wear bikinis and walk everywhere. He then added that only tourists who were, quote, not beautiful should feel safe in bikinis, a comment that sparked international outrage and required the general to issue a public apology. Within days, 60 police officers had descended on Katow to expedite the investigation. Upon inspecting the crime scene, the island's most senior police officer concluded one thing, there was no way the murders were committed by a Thai person. He believed Thai's simply weren't capable of carrying out such a horrendous act of violence. Instead, police focused their attention on foreigners. Yet, the semen staining found on Hannah Witheridge's body was determined to have come from two Asian males.
泰国自封的总理、陆军总司令巴育·占奥差将军在电视上发表讲话，讨论游客安全问题。他评论道：“游客认为我们的国家美丽安全，所以他们可以为所欲为，他们可以穿比基尼到处走。”他随后补充说，只有“不漂亮”的游客在穿比基尼时才应该感到安全，这一言论引发了国际公愤，并要求将军发表公开道歉。几天之内，60名警察抵达涛岛以加快调查速度。在检查犯罪现场后，岛上最高级别的警官得出一个结论：谋杀案绝不可能是泰国人所为。他认为泰国人根本没有能力做出如此可怕的暴力行为。相反，警方将注意力集中在外国人身上。然而，在汉娜·威瑟里奇尸体上发现的精液污渍被确定来自两名亚洲男性。
The DNA of these men was also found on the L&M cigarette butts along with the DNA of a third Asian male. As a result, the ware brothers were officially cleared from the investigation and free to return to the UK. Thai police were now forced to look inwards for potential suspects. The AC bar where Hannah and David were last seen was known to be frequented by groups of aggressive drunken men, and it was theorized that Hannah might have had a confrontation with one, who then followed her and David as they walked back to their hotel. Another possibility was that fishermen could have swam ashore from their boat to commit the crimes, then fled by sea without anyone ever knowing they were in the area. Police began focusing on the large migrant Burmese community that dominated the island. For the roughly 2,000 permanent residents on Catau, there were approximately 5,000 Burmese workers who flocked from their neighbouring country of Myanmar looking for employment. Given that they were willing to work for less money than the Thais, Burmese made up a majority of the island's labour force.
这些男性的DNA也在L&M烟头上被发现，还有第三名亚洲男性的DNA。因此，韦尔兄弟被正式排除在调查之外，并获准返回英国。泰国警方现在被迫向内寻找潜在嫌疑人。汉娜和大卫最后一次露面的AC酒吧以经常有成群结队的醉酒男子出没而闻名，有人推测汉娜可能与其中一人发生了冲突，那人随后在他们走回酒店时跟踪了她和大卫。另一种可能性是渔民可能从船上游上岸实施犯罪，然后从海上逃走，而没有人知道他们在该地区。警方开始关注岛上占主导地位的缅甸移民社区。对于涛岛上约2000名常住居民来说，有大约5000名缅甸工人从邻国缅甸涌入寻找工作。由于他们愿意以比泰国人更低的工资工作，缅甸人占了岛上劳动力的绝大多数。
Many were undocumented and often exploited and treated disrespectfully by Thais who considered them to be of a lower social standing. Burmese workers who lived or worked within the vicinity of the crime scene were rounded up en masse and required to provide DNA samples and footprints to compare to those left in the sand at the murder scene. Documentation was also checked to identify those who were working in the country illegally. Raids were done on several homes, and five Burmese men were put under the spotlight after blood stains were found on some of their clothes. All up, over 200 DNA samples were collected, but none were rematched to the crime scene. 25-year-old Scottish musician Sean McCanna had been living on Catau for some time and was a friend of David Miller's from back home. Crushed to hear what had happened, Sean deeply regretted not going to the AC bar with David on the night he was killed. In the days following the murders, he'd heard many rumours circulating around the island, including that two Thai men had attempted to molest Hannah and David had stepped in, prompting the Thais to kill the pair.
许多人没有证件，经常受到泰国人的剥削和不尊重，泰国人认为他们的社会地位较低。居住或工作在犯罪现场附近的缅甸工人被集体围捕，并被要求提供DNA样本和脚印，以与留在谋杀现场沙滩上的样本进行比对。警方还检查了证件，以确定哪些人在非法工作。几个家庭遭到突袭，五名缅甸男子因衣服上发现血迹而受到关注。总共收集了200多个DNA样本，但没有一个与犯罪现场匹配。25岁的苏格兰音乐家肖恩·麦肯纳已经在涛岛生活了一段时间，是大卫·米勒在家乡的朋友。听到发生的事情，肖恩深感悲痛，他非常后悔在大卫被杀的那晚没有和他一起去AC酒吧。在谋杀案发生后的几天里，他听到了岛上流传的许多谣言，包括两名泰国男子试图骚扰汉娜，大卫介入，导致泰国人杀害了这对情侣。
Drowning his woes at a local bar, a group of local Thai men approached Sean and started asking him questions about his friend. Feeling tipsy, Sean answered them, before one of the men allegedly said, It was you who killed them. You've got two people's deaths on your hands. You are going to hang yourself tonight. We are going to watch you hang. You die tonight. Terrified, Sean got up and ran. He sprinted into a nearby supermarket, but two of the men followed him inside. Thinking quickly about how to protect himself, Sean logged into Facebook on his phone and posted a photo of the men along with the message, Thai mafia are trying to kill me. Please help me. The police eventually escorted Sean back to his hotel, but fearing for his life, he fled into the jungle where he hid overnight, before boarding the first boat off Katow in the morning. He then met up with the reporter for the Daily Telegraph to tell his story, saying he believed the men who approached him knew who had killed Hannah and David and were looking for a scapegoat.
在当地一家酒吧借酒消愁时，一群当地泰国男子走近肖恩，开始问他关于他朋友的问题。喝醉了的肖恩回答了他们，随后其中一名男子据称说：“是你杀了他们。你背负着两条人命。你今晚会自杀的。我们会看着你上吊。你今晚就得死。”惊恐万分的肖恩起身逃跑。他冲进附近的一家超市，但其中两名男子跟着他进去了。肖恩迅速思考如何保护自己，他在手机上登录Facebook，发布了一张这些男人的照片，并附上信息：“泰国黑手党想杀我。请帮帮我。”警察最终护送肖恩回到酒店，但由于担心自己的生命安全，他逃进了丛林，在那里躲了一夜，然后在早上登上了离开涛岛的第一艘船。他随后会见了《每日电讯报》的一名记者讲述了他的故事，说他相信那些接近他的男人知道是谁杀了汉娜和大卫，并且正在寻找替罪羊。
They wanted Sean to take his own life, so that it would fit with their narrative that the killer was a Westerner. When the video of Sean talking about this encounter circulated online, some astute viewers noticed that he had a 2cm long wound on his right forearm that looked remarkably similar to one on David Miller's shoulder. Photos also circulated on social media of Sean's guitar, which he had left on Katow, and it appeared to be splattered with blood. Suspicions arose that Sean could have been involved in the murders, possibly in conjunction with some of his Thai friends, and had created the story about being threatened in order to detract attention from himself. Sean strongly disputed these allegations, explaining that the injuries and blood had come from a bike accident days before the murders. He left the country and went off the grid. Unlike other parts of the world, in Thailand the term mafia doesn't necessarily relate to organised crime, but to the influential families that hold a monopoly over certain areas. Katow initially served as a political prison, with its first permanent inhabitants arriving in the 1930s, long before any authorities.
他们想让肖恩自杀，这样就符合他们关于凶手是西方人的说法。当肖恩谈论这次遭遇的视频在网上流传时，一些敏锐的观众注意到他的右前臂上有一道2厘米长的伤口，看起来和大卫·米勒肩膀上的伤口惊人地相似。肖恩留在涛岛的吉他的照片也在社交媒体上流传，上面似乎溅满了血迹。人们开始怀疑肖恩可能参与了谋杀案，可能与他的一些泰国朋友串通，并编造了被威胁的故事以转移对自己的注意力。肖恩强烈反驳了这些指控，解释说伤口和血迹来自谋杀案发生前几天的自行车事故。他离开了这个国家并隐姓埋名。与世界其他地方不同，在泰国，“黑手党”一词并不一定指有组织犯罪，而是指在某些地区拥有垄断地位的有影响力家族。涛岛最初被用作政治监狱，其第一批常住居民在20世纪30年代到达，远在任何当局之前。
While Katow had since been resettled into a tourist haven, these families still dominated the island, owning a majority of the land and businesses. They held great power and were generally considered the unofficial leaders of the island, the go-to people when any problems arose. The richest and most influential family on Katow was the Doh Wichien family. Feared by many, they owned a majority of the businesses on Siree Beach, including the AC bar and resort where David and Hannah were last seen alive. At the head of the family was Warapan Doh Wichien, followed closely by his brother Mondri Wat, better known as Mon. Mon had been the first person to arrive at the crime scene after the beach cleaner alerted him to the discovery of the bodies. When footage from the scene was broadcast on the news, it struck many as odd that Mon was allowed to join the police in the cordoned off area. He was seen freely walking around the crime scene, which skeptics believe gave him the opportunity to contaminate any evidence while providing a valid explanation as to why any of his DNA might be found.
虽然涛岛后来被重新安置为一个旅游天堂，但这些家族仍然统治着该岛，拥有大部分土地和企业。他们拥有巨大的权力，通常被认为是岛上的非官方领导人，是出现任何问题时的首选人物。涛岛上最富有、最有影响力的家族是Doh Wichien家族。许多人对他们感到恐惧，他们拥有塞里海滩上的大部分企业，包括大卫和汉娜最后一次活着露面的AC酒吧和度假村。家族首领是Warapan Doh Wichien，紧随其后的是他的兄弟Mondri Wat，也就是众所周知的Mon。Mon是海滩清洁工提醒他发现尸体后第一个到达犯罪现场的人。当现场录像在新闻中播出时，许多人觉得Mon被允许加入警察在警戒线内感到奇怪。他被看到在犯罪现场自由走动，怀疑论者认为这让他有机会污染任何证据，同时为为什么可能发现他的任何DNA提供了合理的解释。
Suspicions immediately arose that the Thai mafia were involved in the murders and were working in conjunction with the police to make the problem go away. Some Thai police had a reputation for corruption and were often accused of accepting bribes and protecting those in positions of power. Bolstering these theories was the fact that Mon Doh Wichien was one of the men that Sean McKenna had photographed after they followed him into the supermarket urging him to take his own life. The other was a police officer. As accusations of a cover-up gathered momentum, the police announced they wouldn't be swayed by any local influence and that the mafia would be looked into like anyone else. Just over a week after the double homicide, police announced that Mon Doh Wichien had been taken into custody for questioning after he was captured in CCTV footage in the vicinity of the crime scene around the time the murders took place. They also sought to arrest Mon's nephew, 22-year-old Noomsad Doh Wichien, who bore resemblance to another figure captured in the footage and was reported to have fled the island shortly after the murders. Rumors swelled that Noomsad had hired a speedboat in the early hours of September 15 and was seen speeding towards the mainland, leaving his family to cover for him.
人们立即怀疑泰国黑手党参与了谋杀案，并与警方合作以消除这个问题。一些泰国警察有腐败的名声，经常被指控接受贿赂并保护那些掌权的人。支持这些理论的事实是，Mon Doh Wichien是肖恩·麦肯纳在他们跟踪他进入超市并敦促他自杀后拍摄的男子之一。另一个人是一名警察。随着掩盖真相的指控愈演愈烈，警方宣布他们不会受到任何地方势力的影响，黑手党会像其他人一样受到调查。双重谋杀案发生一周多后，警方宣布Mon Doh Wichien已被拘留审问，因为他在谋杀案发生时被闭路电视录像拍到在犯罪现场附近。他们还试图逮捕Mon的侄子，22岁的Noomsad Doh Wichien，他与录像中拍到的另一个人长相相似，据报道在谋杀案发生后不久就逃离了该岛。谣言四起，称Noomsad在9月15日凌晨租了一艘快艇，被看到向大陆疾驰而去，留下他的家人为他掩护。
Noomsad was eventually located, but he claimed he hadn't been on Katao at the time of the murders at all. He said he'd been over 400km away at university in Bangkok and even had stills taken from CCTV footage to prove it. Concluding this to be a solid alibi, Noomsad was publicly cleared from the investigation, as was his uncle Mon. Mon later explained on the Channel 4 documentary Murder in Paradise that the real reason he chased Sean McKenna into the supermarket was because he wanted to question him about the blood on his guitar. By now, online sleuths had become fixated on the case and they remained convinced that the mafia were involved in Hannah and David's murders. Examining the CCTV stills of Noomsad Doichien in Bangkok, they noticed that the footage hadn't come from the university at all, but from the lobby of Noomsad's Bangkok apartment next door. It was time stamped at 9.15am on September 15, several hours after the murders were thought to have taken place. Some online sleuths speculated that the look of the lobby was outdated, indicating the footage had been captured some time ago, but there was no evidence to support this.
Noomsad最终被找到，但他声称在谋杀案发生时他根本不在涛岛。他说他在400多公里外的曼谷上大学，甚至有从闭路电视录像中截取的剧照来证明这一点。结论是这是一个可靠的不在场证明，Noomsad被公开排除在调查之外，他的叔叔Mon也被排除。Mon后来在第四频道纪录片《天堂谋杀案》中解释说，他追赶肖恩·麦肯纳进入超市的真正原因是想询问他关于吉他上血迹的事。到目前为止，网络侦探已经沉迷于此案，他们仍然确信黑手党参与了汉娜和大卫的谋杀案。检查Noomsad Doichien在曼谷的闭路电视剧照时，他们注意到录像根本不是来自大学，而是来自隔壁Noomsad曼谷公寓的大堂。时间戳是9月15日上午9点15分，在谋杀案被认为发生后的几个小时。一些网络侦探推测大堂的样子已经过时，表明录像是在很久以前拍摄的，但没有证据支持这一点。
Allegations arose that the stills were fake and concerned citizens called for CCTV footage from the university itself to be released. Regardless, police closed the book on the Doichien family. Frustrated by the accusations against his family, Katow Hedman, Warapan Doichien announced the bizarre challenge. If anyone could prove that his family were involved in Hannah and David's murders, he'd pay them 1 million baht, the equivalent to around 40,000 Australian dollars. Two weeks passed without any significant breakthroughs in the case. The police came under criticism from the British press for chasing the wrong leads, publicly naming suspects who were later cleared and for wrongly jumping from one suspect to the next without fully completing each line of inquiry. Thai police rejected an offer of assistance from the British Embassy, saying they were confident that an arrest would soon be made. One BBC journalist remarked,
有指控称这些剧照是伪造的，有关公民呼吁发布大学本身的闭路电视录像。无论如何，警方结案了Doichien家族的调查。涛岛头目Warapan Doichien对针对他家族的指控感到沮丧，宣布了一个奇怪的挑战。如果有人能证明他的家族参与了汉娜和大卫的谋杀案，他将支付他们100万泰铢，相当于约4万澳元。两周过去了，案件没有任何重大突破。警方因追查错误线索、公开点名后来被洗清嫌疑的嫌疑人以及在没有完全完成每条调查线索的情况下错误地从一个嫌疑人跳到另一个嫌疑人而受到英国媒体的批评。泰国警方拒绝了英国大使馆的协助提议，称他们有信心很快就会逮捕凶手。一位BBC记者评论道：
Watching the Thai police struggle to answer this mystery with the eyes of the world on them has felt like being part of a sometimes farcical performance in which we, the media, are the audience. There were roughly 300 CCTV cameras around Siree Beach, but only 106 of them were working on the night that Hannah Witheridge and David Miller were killed. Security cameras at the AC bar didn't face towards the beachside exit, so it couldn't be determined exactly when Hannah and David had left the venue. Given that David had entered around 208am and the pair's bodies had been found around 5am, the murders had occurred somewhere within that time frame. CCTV footage captured in the area within those hours revealed three young Asian males travelling on a motorcycle with a guitar in tow. After stopping at a 7-11 convenience store to buy beer and cigarettes, the trio made their way towards the beach and disappeared from view. Later, at around 3.45am, a security camera at a health restaurant near the crime scene captured an Asian man running shirtless down the street. Although he soon disappeared from view, his shadow could be seen entering a shortcut that led to a nearby bungalow.
“看着泰国警方在全世界的注视下努力回答这个谜团，感觉就像是在参与一场有时是闹剧的表演，而我们媒体就是观众。”塞里海滩周围大约有300个闭路电视摄像头，但在汉娜·威瑟里奇和大卫·米勒被杀的那晚，只有106个在工作。AC酒吧的监控摄像头没有对着海滩出口，因此无法确定汉娜和大卫确切离开该场所的时间。考虑到大卫在凌晨2点08分左右进入，而两人的尸体在凌晨5点左右被发现，谋杀案发生在那个时间段内的某个地方。在该时间段内拍摄的闭路电视录像显示，三名年轻的亚洲男性骑着摩托车，带着一把吉他。在7-11便利店停下来买啤酒和香烟后，三人朝海滩走去，消失在视野中。后来，在凌晨3点45分左右，犯罪现场附近一家健康餐厅的监控摄像头拍到一名亚洲男子赤裸上身在街上奔跑。虽然他很快消失在视野中，但可以看到他的影子进入了一条通往附近平房的捷径。
On October 1, just over two weeks after the murders, police visited the bungalow and found that a young Burmese migrant named Mormor resided there. When asked about his whereabouts on the night of the murders, Mormor said he had gone down to Surrey Beach with two of his friends, Zor-Lyn and Waypo, to play the guitar. They'd sat on a fallen log underneath a pine tree sharing cigarettes and having a few drinks. Mormor then rode the motorcycle to his girlfriend's house. When he returned home, Zor-Lyn and Waypo were there asleep. He didn't notice anything out of the ordinary nor was there anything strange about their behaviour in the days following. Police ordered Mormor to take them to the homes of Zor-Lyn and Waypo for further questioning. At 1am on October 2, a team of police swarmed the house where the men lived with six other workers. 22-year-old Zor-Lyn had grown up poor and uneducated in a remote village in Myanmar's Rakhine state that had no electricity or running water.
10月1日，即谋杀案发生两周多后，警方走访了该平房，发现一名叫Mormor的年轻缅甸移民住在那里。当被问及谋杀案当晚的行踪时，Mormor说他和两个朋友Zor-Lyn和Waypo去了塞里海滩弹吉他。他们坐在松树下的一根倒下的原木上，分享香烟并喝了几杯酒。Mormor随后骑摩托车去了他女朋友家。当他回到家时，Zor-Lyn和Waypo在那里睡觉。他没有注意到任何异常，在接下来的几天里他们的行为也没有什么奇怪的地方。警方命令Mormor带他们去Zor-Lyn和Waypo的住处进行进一步询问。10月2日凌晨1点，一队警察包围了这些人与另外六名工人居住的房子。22岁的Zor-Lyn在缅甸若开邦的一个偏远村庄长大，那里贫穷且没有受过教育，没有电也没有自来水。
His family grew just enough crops and raised just enough livestock to get by. After his father passed away, Zor-Lyn crossed the border into Thailand looking for better paying work and secured a job at a bar on Surrey Beach. Although it didn't pay well, it was more than he could make in Myanmar and he worked hard to send as much money as he could to his mother back home. Police asked to see Zor-Lyn's passport but he couldn't provide one so they placed him under arrest for illegally entering the country. As for 22-year-old Waypo, he was nowhere to be found. Like a Zor-Lyn, Waypo also came from a poor remote village in Myanmar's Rakhine state with very limited resources and had come to Khatau to take advantage of the employment opportunities. He'd recently been offered a new job on the mainland and was currently travelling on an overnight boat that was due to arrive in the city of Surat Tani at 6am. When the boat pulled in, officers found Waypo hiding on board and placed him under arrest when he was unable to provide a passport or valid work permit.
他的家人种的庄稼和养的牲畜刚好够维持生计。父亲去世后，Zor-Lyn越过边境进入泰国寻找报酬更高的工作，并在塞里海滩的一家酒吧找到了一份工作。虽然工资不高，但比他在缅甸能赚到的多，他努力工作，尽可能多地寄钱给家乡的母亲。警方要求查看Zor-Lyn的护照，但他无法提供，因此他们以非法入境为由将他逮捕。至于22岁的Waypo，他不知去向。像Zor-Lyn一样，Waypo也来自缅甸若开邦一个贫穷偏远的村庄，资源非常有限，来到涛岛是为了利用就业机会。他最近在大陆得到了一份新工作，目前正乘坐一艘通宵船，预计于凌晨6点到达素叻他尼市。当船靠岸时，警察发现Waypo躲在船上，在他无法提供护照或有效工作许可证时将他逮捕。
In custody, they were questioned as potential witnesses to the murder of Hannah and David. Both men signed written forms consenting to have their DNA collected. Waypo was taken back to Khatau for questioning and it didn't take long for him to crack. Within hours, Waypo confessed to everything. In Thailand, it is customary for those accused of committing major crimes to participate in a public re-enactment of their offences. The purpose is to help investigators visualise the crimes and to corroborate confessions, but it also serves as a form of public humiliation. Thai culture places a large emphasis on what's known as face, which is similar to the western concept of reputation. Losing face is something that Thai people avoid at all costs and a public re-enactment of one's crimes serves as the ultimate degradation.
在拘留期间，他们作为汉娜和大卫谋杀案的潜在证人受到审问。两人都签署了书面表格，同意采集DNA。Waypo被带回涛岛接受审问，没过多久他就崩溃了。几个小时内，Waypo承认了一切。在泰国，被指控犯有重大罪行的人通常会参加犯罪现场的公开重演。目的是帮助调查人员直观地了解犯罪过程并证实供词，但它也起到了一种公开羞辱的形式。泰国文化非常强调所谓的“面子”，这类似于西方的声誉概念。丢脸是泰国人极力避免的事情，公开重演自己的罪行是终极的贬低。
On October 3, hordes of press and curious onlookers gathered around a siree beach as Xorlin and Waypo were led to the crime scene in handcuffs. Wearing bulletproof vests and helmets for their own protection, the two men used a dustpan in place of the garden hoe. As instructed by the police, Xorlin and Waypo re-enacted their movements from the early hours of the morning on September 15, complete with the guitar. According to the official police report, it all started after their friend Momo left to visit his girlfriend. Xorlin and Waypo remained sitting on a fallen log playing the guitar and smoking cigarettes when through the darkness they saw Hannah and David kissing. In a conservative country where public affection is frowned upon and rarely seen, the sire aroused them. Overcome with sexual jealousy, they decided to knock David out so that they could rape Hannah. The pair found the garden hoe nearby and snuck up behind the couple, striking David on the head several times.
10月3日，大批媒体和好奇的旁观者聚集在塞里海滩，Xorlin和Waypo被戴上手铐带到犯罪现场。为了自身安全，两人穿着防弹背心和头盔，用簸箕代替了锄头。按照警方的指示，Xorlin和Waypo重演了他们9月15日清晨的动作，并带上了吉他。根据官方警方报告，这一切始于他们的朋友Momo离开去见女朋友之后。Xorlin和Waypo坐在倒下的原木上弹吉他、抽烟，这时他们在黑暗中看到汉娜和大卫在接吻。在一个保守的国家，公开亲热是不被赞成的，也很少见到，这种景象激怒了他们。出于性嫉妒，他们决定打晕大卫，以便强奸汉娜。两人在附近找到了锄头，悄悄溜到这对情侣身后，多次击打大卫的头部。
Realising he was dead, they dragged his body into the sea. They then used the hoe to inflict several blows to Hannah's head, rendering her unconscious, at which point they took turns raping her. Afterwards, they knew they had to kill Hannah to conceal what they'd done, so they hit her in the head with the hoe several more times. Waypo then stole David's sunglasses and iPhone. He broke the sunglasses and threw them away, but gave the iPhone to a friend named Ren. Officers went to Ren's home and found the smashed broken iPhone in the backyard. A check of its serial number with British authorities confirmed that it belonged to David Miller. Armed with the confession, the authorities were able to place a rush on the DNA testing, and it was soon revealed that the semen on Hannah's body had come from both Zorlin and Waypo.
意识到他已经死了，他们把他的尸体拖进海里。然后他们用锄头多次击打汉娜的头部，使她失去知觉，此时他们轮流强奸了她。事后，他们知道必须杀死汉娜以掩盖他们的所作所为，所以他们又用锄头击打了她的头部几次。Waypo随后偷走了大卫的太阳镜和iPhone。他弄坏了太阳镜并扔掉了，但把iPhone给了朋友Ren。警察去了Ren的家，在后院发现了被砸碎的iPhone。与英国当局核对序列号后，证实它属于大卫·米勒。有了供词，当局得以加快DNA检测速度，很快发现汉娜尸体上的精液来自Zorlin和Waypo两人。
Their DNA was also found on the murder weapon and on cigarette butts recovered from the crime scene. Zorlin and Waypo were both formally charged with five offences, premeditated murder, killing to conceal a criminal offence, rape, illegal entry into Thailand, and staying in the country without permission. Many members of the public had believed it was just a matter of time before the crimes were blamed on a migrant, and when news hit that the Burmese workers had been arrested for the murders, skepticism ran rife. A commentary in the Bangkok Post explained that the skepticism didn't just stem from the poor handling of the police investigation, but quote, from the police's longstanding notoriety for arresting poor and powerless scapegoats to save rich criminals who can afford to buy their innocence. The public outrage became so strong that police threatened to charge anyone who questioned their findings. The National Police Chief described the investigation as a perfect job, but for the critics, there were several details about Zorlin and Waypo's alleged involvement that raised serious questions. First of all, when the two men were taken into police custody, they were only questioned as witnesses, not suspects.
他们的DNA也在凶器和从犯罪现场回收的烟头上被发现。Zorlin和Waypo都被正式指控犯有五项罪行：蓄意谋杀、杀人以掩盖犯罪、强奸、非法进入泰国以及未经许可在境内停留。许多公众认为将罪行归咎于移民只是时间问题，当缅甸工人因谋杀案被捕的消息传出时，怀疑论盛行。《曼谷邮报》的一篇评论解释说，这种怀疑不仅源于警方调查处理不当，而且“源于警方长期以来因逮捕贫穷无力的替罪羊以拯救有钱购买清白的罪犯而臭名昭著”。公众的愤怒变得如此强烈，以至于警方威胁要起诉任何质疑他们调查结果的人。国家警察局长将这次调查描述为“完美的工作”，但对于批评者来说，关于Zorlin和Waypo涉案的几个细节引发了严重的问题。首先，当这两名男子被警方拘留时，他们只是作为证人而不是嫌疑人受到审问。
It was therefore suspicious that they would both voluntarily confess to such serious crimes in the absence of any incriminating evidence. There was talk that the police might have offered the two Burmese men money in exchange for a confession, which they ignorantly agreed to without realizing the seriousness of the consequences. During the re-enactment of the murders, some noted that Zorlin and Waypo had to be guided every step of the way, as though they had no idea what was expected of them. As described by author Suzanne Buchanan in her book titled The Curse of the Turtle, the true story of Thailand's backpacker murders, the accused were often manhandled into position by the police, and if they pointed in one direction, the police would correct them and they'd then point the opposite way. Suzanne remarked, Zorlin and Waypo visibly had no clue what they were meant to be doing. They had to be physically prompted at every turn by the police who were obviously choreographing the entire thing. The two tiny men looked like puppets on a string. Critics also questioned Zorlin and Waypo's supposed motive. When announcing the arrests, police initially said that the killers had been aroused upon seeing Hannah and David, quote, making love, but this explanation didn't add up. For one, David's DNA wasn't found on Hannah's body, meaning the pair hadn't had sex. Secondly, to say that the killers had been spontaneously motivated by sexual desire contrasted scientific studies about what drives men to rape women.
因此，在没有任何确凿证据的情况下，他们两人会自愿承认如此严重的罪行，这本身就很可疑。有传言称，警方可能曾向这两名缅甸男子提供金钱以换取供词，而他们因无知而同意了，却没意识到后果的严重性。在谋杀案现场重演过程中，一些人注意到，佐林和怀波每一步都需要被引导，仿佛他们根本不知道别人期望他们做什么。正如作家苏珊·布坎南在她的书《海龟的诅咒：泰国背包客谋杀案的真实故事》中所述，被告经常被警察粗暴地摆布到指定位置，如果他们指向一个方向，警察会纠正他们，然后他们就会指向相反的方向。苏珊评论道，佐林和怀波显然根本不知道他们应该做什么。他们每走一步都必须由显然在编排整个过程的警察进行身体上的提示。这两个瘦小的男人看起来就像提线木偶。批评人士还质疑了佐林和怀波所谓的动机。在宣布逮捕时，警方最初称凶手在看到汉娜和戴维“做爱”时产生了性冲动，但这种解释根本站不住脚。首先，戴维的DNA并没有在汉娜的尸体上发现，这意味着两人并没有发生性关系。其次，说凶手是受性欲自发驱动的，这与关于男性强奸女性动机的科学研究相矛盾。
A majority of psychologists believe that rape isn't driven by lust, but is usually an act of premeditated violence driven by the desire for power and control. For some, the police misunderstanding served as further proof that they were creating a narrative against the two accused in the absence of any real motive. There was also the question of whether Zorlin and Waypo were physically capable of overpowering two victims. Both of the Burmese men were very slight in stature, only standing around five foot tall, whereas David Miller was roughly six foot two with an athletic build. Striking David in the head, overpowering him and dragging his body into the water while simultaneously restraining Hannah would have been no easy feat for two men of the accused's size. Furthermore, 20 days had passed between the murders taking place and Zorlin and Waypo being arrested, yet the pair had made no attempt to flee the island. Reports stated that Waypo was arrested when trying to escape on a boat to Surat Tani, but Waypo claimed he'd simply been visiting the mainland to start a new job. If the two Burmese migrants were responsible for the murders, it made sense that they would have left the island as soon as possible to escape not just the authorities, but also the local mafia.
大多数心理学家认为，强奸并非由欲望驱动，通常是一种由权力和控制欲驱动的预谋暴力行为。对一些人来说，警方的误解进一步证明了他们在没有任何真实动机的情况下，编造了针对两名被告的叙事。还有一个问题是，佐林和怀波是否有能力制服两名受害者。这两名缅甸男子身材都非常瘦小，身高只有五英尺左右，而戴维·米勒身高约六英尺二英寸，体格健壮。对于两个被告这样体型的人来说，要击中戴维的头部、制服他并将他的尸体拖入水中，同时还要控制住汉娜，绝非易事。此外，从谋杀发生到佐林和怀波被捕已经过去了20天，但两人并没有试图逃离该岛。有报道称，怀波在试图乘船逃往素叻他尼时被捕，但怀波声称他只是去大陆找一份新工作。如果这两名缅甸移民是谋杀案的凶手，那么他们理应尽快离开该岛，以逃避不仅是当局，还有当地黑帮的追捕。
These details aside, some were also suspicious about the police handling of the evidence. David's body and clothing belonging to both him and Hannah had been moved shortly after officers first arrived at the crime scene, potentially disturbing evidence. Police explained they did this to avoid the items being washed away by the tide, but the tide had already gone out for the day and it was therefore unlikely that the items would be dragged away by the current. Human rights groups had been following Hannah and David's case and were concerned that Zorlin and Waypo had been treated unfairly. From the get-go, it was clear that police didn't want the killer to be tied. Not only had one of the lead investigators said there was no way a Thai person could be capable of such a crime, the sub-district head of Katau commented, If another foreigner killed Hannah and David, then the damage for us won't be too bad. If it's something else, it could really hurt our reputation. When Zorlin and Waypo were arrested, the DNA consent forms and statements they signed were both written in Thai.
撇开这些细节不谈，一些人还对警方处理证据的方式表示怀疑。在警察首次到达犯罪现场后不久，戴维的尸体以及属于他和汉娜的衣物就被移动了，这可能破坏了证据。警方解释说，他们这样做是为了防止物品被潮水冲走，但当时潮水已经退去，因此这些物品不太可能被水流冲走。人权组织一直在关注汉娜和戴维的案件，并担心佐林和怀波受到了不公正的对待。从一开始，就很明显警方不想让真正的凶手被抓获。不仅其中一名首席调查员曾说泰国人不可能犯下这样的罪行，卡陶的副区长还评论道：“如果另一个外国人杀了汉娜和戴维，对我们来说损失不会太大。如果是其他情况，可能会严重损害我们的声誉。”当佐林和怀波被捕时，他们签署的DNA同意书和声明都是用泰语书写的。
However, neither of the Burmese men could speak or read Thai. They'd been provided with a Burmese translator, but he wasn't an official court-appointed translator. He was a Burmese pancake vendor who spoke neither Thai, nor Zorlin and Waypo's native Rakhine dialect. The pancake vendor was also part of an ethnic minority that had a long history of conflict with Myanmar's Rakhine state, which is where Zorlin and Waypo came from. There were also concerns that the public re-enactment, which human rights groups viewed as antiquated, would harm the accused's right to a fair trial. Officials from the Myanmar Embassy visited Zorlin and Waypo in jail, along with members of Thailand's National Human Rights Commission, the Lawyers' Council of Thailand, and the Migrant Workers' Rights Network. They determined that both men were naive, uneducated, and easily coerced. Along with the forced DNA testing and questionable translator, the accused hadn't been appointed a lawyer or told of their rights.
然而，这两名缅甸男子都不会说也不会读泰语。他们虽然被提供了一名缅甸语翻译，但他并不是法院指定的官方翻译。他是一名缅甸煎饼小贩，既不会说泰语，也不会说佐林和怀波的母语若开语。这名煎饼小贩还属于一个与缅甸若开邦（佐林和怀波的家乡）有着长期冲突历史的少数民族。人们还担心，人权组织认为过时的公开重演会损害被告获得公平审判的权利。缅甸大使馆的官员与泰国国家人权委员会、泰国律师协会和移民工人权利网络的成员一起在监狱中探望了佐林和怀波。他们认定这两名男子天真、未受过教育，且容易受到胁迫。除了强制性的DNA检测和有问题的翻译外，被告也没有被指派律师，也没有被告知他们的权利。
They didn't seem to understand the full weight of the crimes they'd been accused of, nor the fact that they wouldn't be released anytime soon. Another detail that couldn't be overlooked was the fact that the two young men appeared to be sporting several bruises. Zorlin and Waypo told these organisations that what really happened on the night of the murders was that they'd met at Mormor's workplace, which was part of a resort owned by the Dorwichian family. They waited around for Mormor to finish, and the trio then purchased some beer and cigarettes from a 7-Eleven before riding a motorbike down to Syri Beach. At around 2am, they sat on a fallen log playing a guitar that Zorlin had brought with him. It was dark, and they couldn't see more than roughly 5 metres in front of them. They spent roughly an hour playing the guitar while passing the beers and cigarettes between them. Mormor then left for a while, at which point Zorlin and Waypo made another quick trip to the convenience store to buy two more bottles of beer.
他们似乎并不了解自己所受指控的严重性，也不明白他们不会很快被释放。另一个不容忽视的细节是，这两名年轻人身上似乎有多处淤青。佐林和怀波告诉这些组织，谋杀案当晚真正发生的事情是，他们在莫莫的工作场所见面，那是多维奇安家族拥有的一个度假村的一部分。他们等莫莫下班，然后三人从7-Eleven便利店买了一些啤酒和香烟，骑摩托车去了叙利亚海滩。凌晨2点左右，他们坐在倒下的原木上，弹奏着佐林带来的吉他。天很黑，他们看不清前方大约5米以外的东西。他们花了大约一个小时弹吉他，同时轮流喝啤酒和抽烟。莫莫随后离开了一会儿，这时佐林和怀波又快速去便利店买了另外两瓶啤酒。
Shortly after they returned to the beach, Mormor rejoined them, but he didn't stay long before heading off to visit his girlfriend. It started to lightly rain, so Zorlin and Waypo decided to call it a night. As they made their way along the beach, Zorlin decided to take a quick dip in the sea in the hopes of curbing a nagging headache. He placed the guitar down and jumped into the water fully clothed. Waypo decided to join him, taking off his shoes and shirt and piling them onto the shore. They swam for around 15 minutes, and when they got out, Waypo's shoes, shirt and the guitar were missing. There was a group of about 20 people watching a fire-twirling show outside the AC bar, but other than that, they hadn't seen anyone pass by. At no point did they see Hannah Witheridge or David Miller.
他们回到海滩后不久，莫莫就加入了他们，但他没待多久就去见他的女朋友了。天开始下起小雨，所以佐林和怀波决定结束这一晚。当他们沿着海滩走时，佐林决定去海里快速游个泳，希望能缓解恼人的头痛。他放下吉他，穿着衣服跳进了水里。怀波决定加入他，脱掉鞋子和衬衫，堆在岸上。他们游了大约15分钟，当他们出来时，怀波的鞋子、衬衫和吉他都不见了。有一群大约20人在AC酒吧外看火舞表演，除此之外，他们没有看到任何人经过。他们自始至终都没有看到汉娜·威瑟里奇或戴维·米勒。
The two men walked around looking for their belongings but couldn't find them, so they decided to make the short walk back to Mormor's bungalow, taking a shortcut down a nearby laneway. Mormor was still at his girlfriend's house, so Zorlin and Waypo let themselves inside. Zorlin hung his wet clothes out to dry and went to bed, but Waypo couldn't relax. The missing shirt he'd been wearing belonged to Mormor, and he wanted to return it, plus he needed his shoes for work the next day. Waypo returned to the beach on his own, but still couldn't find the missing items. Admitting defeat, he walked back to Mormor's house, finding an iPhone and pair of sunglasses along the way, which he decided to keep. He got back to Mormor's bungalow around 4am, with Mormor returning from his girlfriend's shortly after. The next morning, Zorlin and Waypo returned to the village where they both lived.
两人四处寻找他们的财物，但没找到，于是他们决定步行回到莫莫的平房，抄近路走过附近的一条小巷。莫莫还在他女朋友家，所以佐林和怀波自己进去了。佐林把湿衣服挂起来晾干并上床睡觉，但怀波无法放松。他穿的那件丢失的衬衫是莫莫的，他想还回去，而且他第二天工作还需要鞋子。怀波独自回到海滩，但仍然找不到丢失的物品。承认失败后，他走回莫莫的房子，途中发现了一部iPhone和一副太阳镜，他决定留着。他在凌晨4点左右回到莫莫的平房，莫莫不久后也从他女朋友那里回来了。第二天早上，佐林和怀波回到了他们居住的村庄。
Waypo showed the iPhone to his friend Ren. Waypo tried to turn the phone on, but it required a passcode, so he plugged it into Ren's charger and left it there before heading off for work. When Ren later heard about Hannah and David's murders, he panicked. Realising that Waypo had found the iPhone right near the crime scene, Ren smashed the phone to pieces and hid it behind his house, out of fear that he'd be implicated in the crime. The two accused claimed this was the same version of events that they'd given when they were first taken in for questioning, but the police didn't believe them. Instead, they'd taken DNA samples without Zorlin and Waypo's consent and forced them to sign documents written in Thai which they didn't understand. When Zorlin denied committing the murders, the Burmese translator attacked him, threatening that he'd be killed and thrown to sea. The translator urged him to confess, saying that he'd only get four or five years in prison as opposed to certain death.
怀波把iPhone给他的朋友任看。怀波试图打开手机，但需要密码，所以他把它插在任的充电器上，然后就去上班了。当任后来听说汉娜和戴维被谋杀的消息时，他惊慌失措。意识到怀波在犯罪现场附近发现了iPhone，任出于害怕自己会被牵连进这起罪行，把手机砸得粉碎并藏在他家后面。两名被告声称，这就是他们第一次被带去审讯时给出的版本，但警察不相信他们。相反，他们在未经佐林和怀波同意的情况下提取了DNA样本，并强迫他们签署了他们看不懂的泰文文件。当佐林否认犯下谋杀罪时，缅甸翻译攻击了他，威胁说他会被杀并扔进海里。翻译敦促他认罪，说他只会坐牢四五年，而不是必死无疑。
Both men claimed that police tortured them by stripping them naked and leaving them in heavily air-conditioned rooms with blindfolds and handcuffs on. A plastic bag was placed over Zorlin's head in an attempt to suffocate him. Waypo was beaten and had his testicles electrocuted. At one point, the police allegedly said that other Burmese workers had been burnt to death on the island and warned. Those who don't have passports don't have rights. If they disappear, nobody would notice. Humiliated, terrified and in agony, Zorlin and Waypo eventually couldn't take it anymore. Both men reluctantly confessed to the crime. At no point were they informed of the charges against them or of their rights to a lawyer.
两人都声称警察通过剥光他们的衣服，把他们关在空调开得很足的房间里，并蒙住眼睛和戴上手铐来折磨他们。一个塑料袋被套在佐林的头上，试图让他窒息。怀波遭到殴打，睾丸受到电击。有一次，警察据称说岛上还有其他缅甸工人被活活烧死，并警告说：“没有护照的人就没有权利。如果他们消失了，没人会注意到。”佐林和怀波感到羞辱、恐惧和痛苦，最终无法再忍受了。两人不情愿地承认了罪行。他们自始至终都没有被告知对他们的指控，也没有被告知他们聘请律师的权利。
When Zorlin and Waypo were whisked off to Siree Beach to stage a re-enactment the next day, they claimed the Burmese translator dictated their every move, instructing them what to do and say. A legal team from the Lawyers' Council of Thailand agreed to take on the case pro bono and almost two months after Hannah and David's murders, Zorlin and Waypo formally retracted their earlier statements and both declared that they'd be pleading not guilty to the crime. Myanmar officials warned that unfair treatment of Zorlin and Waypo could harm the relationship between the two countries, but Thai police staunchly denied the allegations of torture. They maintained that their interrogations had been done by the book and both of the accused had confessed at their own volition. The public prosecutor stated that the retracted confessions wouldn't have any impact on the case due to the strength of the forensic evidence. The families of Hannah Witheridge and David Miller slammed the reports that Zorlin and Waypo had been used as scapegoats and expressed confidence in the investigation. The Millers said, From what we have seen, the suspects have a difficult case to answer. The evidence against them appears to be powerful and convincing.
当佐林和怀波第二天被匆匆带到西里海滩进行现场重演时，他们声称缅甸翻译指挥了他们的一举一动，指示他们做什么和说什么。泰国律师协会的一个法律团队同意无偿接手此案，在汉娜和戴维被谋杀近两个月后，佐林和怀波正式撤回了他们之前的陈述，并都宣布他们将对该罪行进行无罪抗辩。缅甸官员警告说，对佐林和怀波的不公正待遇可能会损害两国之间的关系，但泰国警方坚决否认了酷刑指控。他们坚持认为审讯是按程序进行的，两名被告都是自愿认罪的。检察官表示，由于法医证据确凿，撤回供词不会对案件产生任何影响。汉娜·威瑟里奇和戴维·米勒的家人抨击了关于佐林和怀波被当作替罪羊的报道，并对调查表示信心。米勒一家说：“从我们所看到的来看，嫌疑人很难为自己辩护。针对他们的证据似乎强有力且令人信服。”
For supporters of Zorlin and Waypo, the DNA evidence that supposedly linked them to the crime scene was also dubious. The authorities had never provided the detailed DNA test results which should include statistical data analysis and a probability ratio. Instead, they merely presented a one-page report that contained handwritten alterations to the dates and no stamp to confirm that the DNA had been tested in a laboratory that complied with internationally accepted standards. There was no documented chain of custody or case notes as would be required in any Western country. Furthermore, DNA testing is a complex process that can take a significant amount of time, but in Zorlin and Waypo's case, investigators were able to produce a result in around 24 hours. These discrepancies prompted accusations that the DNA evidence had either been planted or manipulated to frame the accused. Jane Torpen, an Australian expert on DNA profiling who looked at the evidence, said, Crime scenes are notoriously difficult to gather quality DNA samples from.
对于佐林和怀波的支持者来说，据称将他们与犯罪现场联系起来的DNA证据也令人怀疑。当局从未提供详细的DNA测试结果，这些结果应该包括统计数据分析和概率比。相反，他们仅仅提交了一份单页报告，其中包含对手写日期的修改，并且没有印章来确认DNA是在符合国际公认标准的实验室中测试的。没有像任何西方国家所要求的那样记录监管链或案件记录。此外，DNA测试是一个复杂的过程，可能需要大量时间，但在佐林和怀波的案件中，调查人员在大约24小时内就得出了结果。这些差异引发了人们的指控，即DNA证据要么是被栽赃的，要么是被操纵以陷害被告。简·托彭是一位研究DNA分析的澳大利亚专家，她在查看了证据后说：“犯罪现场很难收集到高质量的DNA样本。”
Cases like the one on Katao which deal with mixed samples are fraught with danger. Complex and sometimes unreliable statistical calculations must be carried out to determine the probability that someone other than the accused could match the recovered sample. Torpen challenged the police's statement that the DNA was confirmed to have come from the accused, explaining, DNA profiling is predicated on statistics, that's the whole point. You don't just say it's a match, it's not fingerprinting. You need to give significance to that match. For the skeptics, one major question remained, if Zorlin and Waypo didn't kill Hannah and David, then who did? Katao was advertised as a safe destination and it was widely reported that a Westerner hadn't fallen victim to a homicide on the island for over a decade,
像卡陶岛这样处理混合样本的案件充满了危险。必须进行复杂且有时不可靠的统计计算，以确定除被告之外的其他人与回收样本匹配的概率。托彭质疑警方关于DNA被证实来自被告的声明，解释说：“DNA分析是基于统计学的，这才是重点。你不能只说这是一个匹配，这不是指纹识别。你需要赋予该匹配以意义。”对于怀疑论者来说，一个主要问题仍然存在：如果佐林和怀波没有杀死汉娜和戴维，那么是谁干的？卡陶岛被宣传为一个安全的目的地，据广泛报道，十多年来岛上没有西方人成为凶杀案的受害者，
but some believed this wasn't necessarily the case. Prior to Hannah and David's murder, a couple of incidents had occurred that had people talking. In August 2012, 32-year-old British IT consultant Ben Harrington was holidaying on Siree Beach with his brother and a friend when he ventured out on a motorbike to get a beer at a nearby bar. Shortly after, Ben's lifeless body was found on the side of a quiet road. Police determined that he had accidentally ridden the bike into a cement electricity pole, fatally breaking his neck to the point that it was twisted back 180 degrees. Ben's family wasn't convinced. Thai authorities were eager to cremate Ben's body straight after his death, but the Harringtons refused and fought hard to have Ben's remains repatriated for a post-mortem. When his body was returned, his wallet and cash were missing, leading the Harringtons to suspect that Ben might have been robbed and then killed to cover it up.
但有些人认为情况未必如此。在汉娜和戴维被谋杀之前，发生过几起让人们议论纷纷的事件。2012年8月，32岁的英国IT顾问本·哈林顿和他的兄弟及一位朋友在西里海滩度假，当时他骑摩托车出去到附近的一家酒吧喝啤酒。不久之后，本毫无生气的尸体被发现躺在一条安静的道路边。警方认定他意外地将摩托车骑进了水泥电线杆，导致颈部致命骨折，甚至扭转了180度。本的家人并不相信。泰国当局急于在本死后立即火化他的尸体，但哈林顿一家拒绝了，并努力争取将本的遗体运回国进行尸检。当他的尸体被送回时，他的钱包和现金不见了，这导致哈林顿一家怀疑本可能被抢劫，然后被杀以掩盖罪行。
An autopsy performed in the UK revealed there were no marks on Ben's neck, nor was his neck broken. A coronial inquest was unable to determine whether Ben had indeed died of an accident, but confirmed his death was due to a ruptured aorta caused by some sort of collision. 15 months later, the four-member Pearson family travelled to Katow from their home in the English city of Derby to ring in the New Year together. On New Year's Eve, they celebrated with dinner at a Siree Beach restaurant before retiring to the nearby Hillside Resort at around 1.30am. 25-year-old Nick Pearson had injured his knee a few days prior and required help from his father to hobble to his bungalow, but other than that, he was in good spirits. The next morning, when Nick's family went to check on him, the door to his room was locked, but Nick wasn't inside. Shortly after, scuba divers traversing the waters in front of the Hillside Resort found Nick's body floating in the sea. He was still wearing the same clothes that he'd worn to bed.
在英国进行的尸检显示，本的脖子上没有痕迹，脖子也没有断。验尸官无法确定本是否确实死于事故，但证实他的死亡是由于某种碰撞导致的主动脉破裂。15个月后，四口之家的皮尔逊一家从他们位于英国德比市的家中前往卡陶岛，一起迎接新年。除夕夜，他们在西里海滩的一家餐厅享用晚餐，然后在凌晨1点30分左右回到附近的希尔赛德度假村。25岁的尼克·皮尔逊几天前膝盖受伤，需要父亲的帮助才能蹒跚走到他的平房，但除此之外，他精神状态良好。第二天早上，当尼克的家人去查看他时，他的房门锁着，但尼克不在里面。不久之后，在希尔赛德度假村前水域穿行的水肺潜水员发现了尼克漂浮在海中的尸体。他仍然穿着睡觉时穿的衣服。
Police determined that he'd drowned after a likely falling 50 feet from his bungalow above, but for the Pearson family, this didn't add up. For one, Nick hadn't sustained a single broken bone. The cliffside was also full of imposing boulders, and if Nick had fallen, one of the rocks would have likely caught his fall, or his body would be badly injured. Police considered it an open and shut case, but the Pearson family suspected foul play. Rumours circulated that Nick could have gotten on the wrong side of locals after taking a liking to one of their girlfriends the day before his death. When the Pearson started making their own inquiries, they were warned to leave Katow, as there were powerful people who lived on the island. Nick's body was returned to the UK, where a coroner was unable to exclude the possibility that he had been assaulted prior to his death, and recorded an open verdict. When Nick's parents heard about the murders of Hannah Witheridge and David Miller, Nick's mother Tracy told reporters for the mirror,
警方认定他在从上方50英尺的平房坠落后溺水身亡，但对于皮尔逊一家来说，这说不通。首先，尼克没有遭受任何骨折。悬崖边也到处都是巨大的巨石，如果尼克摔倒了，其中一块岩石很可能会挡住他的坠落，或者他的身体会受到严重伤害。警方认为这是一起结案的案件，但皮尔逊一家怀疑有谋杀嫌疑。有传言称，尼克在去世前一天看上了当地人的女朋友，可能得罪了当地人。当皮尔逊一家开始自己调查时，他们被警告离开卡陶岛，因为岛上住着有权势的人。尼克的尸体被送回英国，验尸官无法排除他在死前遭到袭击的可能性，并记录了一个开放式裁决。当尼克的父母听说汉娜·威瑟里奇和戴维·米勒被谋杀的消息时，尼克的母亲特雷西告诉《镜报》的记者，
we don't believe the men they've arrested for killing Hannah and David have anything to do with it. It's just a plan to show the police have acted so they don't put tourists off. As soon as I saw the news about Hannah and David, I cried for them and their parents, because I know how hard it is to get the truth on that island. For 23-year-old Sam Venning, his 2013 holiday to Katow seemed like a distant memory, but when he saw the news about the double murders on Siree Beach, it all came rushing back. The location where the crime took place was all too familiar. Horror washed over Sam as he realised, it could have easily been me in that body bag. 15 months earlier, Sam had been drinking at a Katow bar with 20-year-old Canadian backpacker Carla Bartell.
“我们不相信他们逮捕的杀害汉娜和戴维的人与此有关。这只是一个计划，表明警方已经采取了行动，这样他们就不会让游客望而却步。当我看到关于汉娜和戴维的新闻时，我为他们和他们的父母哭了，因为我知道在那个岛上查明真相有多难。”对于23岁的萨姆·文宁来说，他2013年的卡陶岛假期似乎已是遥远的记忆，但当他看到关于西里海滩双重谋杀案的新闻时，一切都涌上心头。犯罪发生的地点太熟悉了。当萨姆意识到“那具尸袋里的人很容易就是我”时，恐惧席卷了他。15个月前，萨姆曾在卡陶岛的一家酒吧与20岁的加拿大背包客卡拉·巴特尔喝酒。
When the venue closed, the pair headed down to the southern end of Siree Beach, sitting on a wall near the exact spot that David and Hannah had been murdered. Chatting in the dark, they suddenly heard a motorbike pull-up, followed by the scuffle of flip-flops. Split seconds later, two masked men appeared. Carla instantly got up and ran, screaming for help. Before Sam could fully comprehend what was happening, he felt something hard strike the side of his head. He fell backwards, the sand beneath breaking his fall. When he came two moments later, blood was dripping down his face.
当酒吧关门时，两人前往西里海滩的南端，坐在离戴维和汉娜被谋杀的确切地点附近的一堵墙上。在黑暗中聊天时，他们突然听到一辆摩托车停下，随后是人字拖的摩擦声。几秒钟后，两名蒙面男子出现了。卡拉立刻站起来跑开，尖叫着求救。在萨姆完全理解发生了什么之前，他感到有什么坚硬的东西击中了他的头部一侧。他向后倒去，下面的沙子缓冲了他的跌落。当他几分钟后醒来时，血正顺着他的脸流下来。
The men had disappeared, but Carla's hysterical screams still echoed through the night. Carla and Sam had no idea what motivated the attack, but they believed the perpetrators had been scared off by Carla's screams. They didn't report the incident, choosing to forget and move on, but after Hannah and David were murdered, they wondered whether they might have narrowly escaped a similar fate. Carla and Sam didn't get a good look of their attackers through the dark, but they did notice one thing. The men were of average height and build, not short, like Zorlin and Waipio. Realizing this information could be vital to the Witheridge-Miller investigation,
男人们消失了，但卡拉歇斯底里的尖叫声仍在夜空中回荡。卡拉和萨姆不知道是什么动机导致了这次袭击，但他们相信肇事者是被卡拉的尖叫声吓跑的。他们没有报告这起事件，选择忘记并继续生活，但在汉娜和戴维被谋杀后，他们想知道自己是否可能侥幸逃脱了类似的命运。卡拉和萨姆在黑暗中没有看清袭击者的长相，但他们确实注意到了一件事。男人们的身高和体格都很普通，并不像佐林和怀波那样矮小。意识到这些信息对威瑟里奇-米勒调查可能至关重要，
both Carla and Sam contacted the relevant Thai authorities wanting to provide a statement. Neither of them ever heard another word. While Zorlin and Waipio awaited trial, controversy continued to haunt Katao. On New Year's Eve of 2014, 29-year-old Frenchman Dimitri Povs welcomed the New Year by partying all night with a group of friends. Dimitri had been living on Katao, and at around 11am on New Year's Day, he headed home alone to his rented bungalow. Hours later, his lifeless body was found hanging from the rafters of his front balcony. Police arrived and found a note nearby, concluding it an open and shut case of suicide. But when photos circulated online, others were skeptical.
卡拉和萨姆都联系了相关的泰国当局，希望提供一份声明。他们两人再也没有收到任何消息。在佐林和怀波等待审判期间，争议继续困扰着卡陶岛。2014年除夕夜，29岁的法国人迪米特里·波夫斯与一群朋友彻夜狂欢，迎接新年。迪米特里一直住在卡陶岛，元旦上午11点左右，他独自一人回到租来的平房。几个小时后，他毫无生气的尸体被发现悬挂在他前阳台的椽子上。警察赶到并在附近发现了一张纸条，将其定性为一起自杀结案。但当照片在网上流传时，其他人表示怀疑。
The noose, which was noticeably loose, had been fashioned from a pair of shoe laces, and oddly, there were no significant marks around Dimitri's neck. His loved ones were adamant that he'd given no indication that he'd been depressed or was having suicidal thoughts. But most suspiciously, when Dimitri's body was found, his hands were tied behind his back. Word on the island was that he'd been romantically interested in a woman who was involved with the local mafia. Just three weeks later, the parents of 23-year-old Christina Anasly became worried when they hadn't heard from their daughter in several days. Christina had recently travelled solo to Katow from England and had told her parents that she'd come down with a painful chest infection. At 6am on January 21, 2015, a cleaner found Christina deceased in her Siree Beach hotel room.
那个明显很松的绞索是用一双鞋带做成的，奇怪的是，迪米特里的脖子上没有明显的痕迹。他的亲人坚信他没有任何迹象表明他抑郁或有自杀念头。但最可疑的是，当迪米特里的尸体被发现时，他的双手被绑在背后。岛上的传言说，他曾对一名与当地黑帮有染的女性产生过浪漫兴趣。仅仅三周后，23岁的克里斯蒂娜·安斯利的父母在几天没有收到女儿的消息后感到担忧。克里斯蒂娜最近独自从英国前往卡陶岛，并告诉父母她患上了痛苦的胸部感染。2015年1月21日凌晨6点，一名清洁工发现克里斯蒂娜死在她的西里海滩酒店房间里。
She was lying face down with a bloody nose. Police determined that she'd died from natural causes after lethally mixing alcohol with antibiotics and painkillers, both of which she'd bought over the counter at a nearby pharmacy. Christina's parents weren't convinced. They'd heard the allegations of police cover-ups in Thailand and requested that their daughter's body be returned to the UK for an autopsy. By the time Christina's body arrived on home soil, it had already been embalmed, meaning that a toxicology report couldn't be conducted. With more suspicious deaths of tourists on Katow, tensions escalated as the trial of Zorlin and Waipio drew near. Reports continued to circulate that the police were covering for the mafia and that locals who knew the truth about who killed Hannah Witheridge and David Miller had fled the island out of concerns for their own safety.
她脸朝下躺着，鼻子流血。警方认定她死于自然原因，因为她将酒精与抗生素和止痛药混合服用，而这两种药都是她在附近药店买的。克里斯蒂娜的父母并不相信。他们听说了泰国警方掩盖真相的指控，并要求将女儿的尸体送回英国进行尸检。当克里斯蒂娜的尸体到达家乡时，它已经被防腐处理了，这意味着无法进行毒理学报告。随着卡陶岛上更多可疑的游客死亡事件发生，随着佐林和怀波审判的临近，紧张局势升级。有报道称，警方在为黑帮掩盖真相，而知道谁杀害了汉娜·威瑟里奇和戴维·米勒真相的当地人出于对自己安全的担忧已经逃离了该岛。
Lawyers for the defence were coming up against hurdle after hurdle. Not only were they denied access to a 900-page police report that formed the basis of the prosecution's case, witnesses from the Burmese community weren't willing to testify because they were too afraid to come forward. The defence team were forced to build their case by relying heavily on media speculation. After being granted several extensions, the trial finally commenced in the Kos Samoyi Provincial Court in July 2015. David Miller's parents and brother travelled to Thailand to be there for the proceedings, first stopping at the scene of the crime to lay mementos in David's honour. David's father, Ian, said they had come with an open mind. Acknowledging the speculation that was running rampant online, Ian said, We are here for David because of his tragic death. We'll go with the flow as much as we can. We won't comment on the trial process. We'll be dignified for David.
辩护律师遇到了一个又一个障碍。他们不仅被拒绝查阅构成检方案件基础的900页警方报告，缅甸社区的证人也不愿作证，因为他们太害怕而不敢站出来。辩护团队被迫主要依靠媒体猜测来建立他们的案件。在获得几次延期后，审判终于于2015年7月在苏梅岛省法院开始。戴维·米勒的父母和兄弟前往泰国参加诉讼，首先在犯罪现场停留，为纪念戴维留下了纪念品。戴维的父亲伊恩说，他们是带着开放的心态来的。承认网上流传的猜测，伊恩说：“我们来到这里是为了戴维，因为他的悲惨死亡。我们会尽可能顺其自然。我们不会评论审判过程。我们会为戴维保持尊严。”
A crowdfunding appeal organised by Hannah Witheridge's sister Laura helped cover the costs for Hannah's family to attend the trial, but the family clarified they wouldn't be making any public comments. In Thailand, criminal trials are overseen by a panel of three judges with no jury present. In this instance, press weren't allowed into the courtroom and the public were forbidden from taking notes. The proceedings were hurled entirely in Thai, although English translators were present so that the victim's families could stay abreast of what was happening. The days were long and exhausting, with some court sessions running for over 10 hours. According to the book The Curse of the Turtle, The True Story of Thailand's Backpacker Murders, the public prosecutor and one of the judges often fell asleep, while the leading judge sometimes got up in the middle of proceedings and left the courtroom. The defence argued that the police investigation was botched and inadequate, and that tunnel vision on Zorlin and Waipio had prevented police from chasing any other leads. The accused's status as a legal migrants made them vulnerable and convenient scapegoats, leading to unlawful treatment while in police custody.
由汉娜·威瑟里奇的姐姐劳拉组织的众筹呼吁帮助支付了汉娜家人参加审判的费用，但家人澄清说他们不会发表任何公开评论。在泰国，刑事审判由三名法官组成的合议庭监督，没有陪审团。在这种情况下，媒体不被允许进入法庭，公众也被禁止做笔记。诉讼程序完全用泰语进行，尽管有英语翻译在场，以便受害者的家人能够了解正在发生的事情。日子漫长而令人疲惫，一些法庭会议持续了超过10个小时。根据《海龟的诅咒：泰国背包客谋杀案的真实故事》一书，检察官和其中一名法官经常睡着，而首席法官有时会在诉讼过程中起身离开法庭。辩方辩称，警方调查拙劣且不充分，对佐林和怀波的“隧道视野”阻止了警方追查任何其他线索。被告作为合法移民的身份使他们变得脆弱且方便成为替罪羊，导致他们在警方拘留期间受到非法对待。
The prosecution stood by the forensic evidence as proof of the defendant's guilt. Yet, because Zorlin and Waipio didn't know what they were consenting to when they signed a DNA consent form, the defence argued that the DNA evidence should be inadmissible. Their request was denied. Testifying for the defence was Dr Kun Jeen Pornthip, one of Thailand's leading forensic pathologists. According to Dr Pornthip, DNA testing in Thailand is incorrect in 60% of cases. She expressed her doubts about the accuracy of the DNA taken from the Siree Beach crime scene and the way these samples were handled. The police had reported that DNA from the accused had been found on the murder weapon. Dr Pornthip had tested the murder weapon in her laboratory and found DNA from David Miller and an unknown Asian male, but none from Zorlin or Waipio.
检方坚持认为法医证据是证明被告有罪的证据。然而，由于佐林和怀波在签署DNA同意书时不知道他们同意的是什么，辩方辩称DNA证据应该是不可采信的。他们的请求被拒绝了。为辩方作证的是泰国领先的法医病理学家之一坤·金·波恩蒂普博士。据波恩蒂普博士称，泰国的DNA测试在60%的案件中是不正确的。她对从西里海滩犯罪现场提取的DNA的准确性以及这些样本的处理方式表示怀疑。警方报告称，在凶器上发现了被告的DNA。波恩蒂普博士在她的实验室测试了凶器，发现了戴维·米勒和一名身份不明的亚洲男性的DNA，但没有发现佐林或怀波的DNA。
Although when questioned by the prosecution, she conceded that this could be explained by the accused having worn gloves or washing the weapon. The prosecution were undeterred by this testimony, as they believed the semen found on Hannah's body indisputably linked the accused to the crime. The defence therefore requested that the DNA from the semen samples be independently retested, arguing that the evidence wasn't collected, tested or analysed properly. Their request was denied by police on the grounds that the sample had been used up and was no longer viable. The trial continued sporadically over the course of several months until the verdict was handed down on December 24, 2015. Families of both the victims and the accused gathered outside the courtroom along with members of the press, as Zorlin and Waipio were led inside wearing shackles and orange prison jumpsuits. The mothers of the accused had been brought in from Myanmar and began wailing hysterically when they saw their sons. Waipio's mother pleaded,
尽管在受到检方质询时，她承认这可以通过被告戴着手套或清洗凶器来解释。检方并没有被这一证词吓倒，因为他们认为在汉娜尸体上发现的精液无可争议地将被告与该罪行联系起来。因此，辩方要求对精液样本中的DNA进行独立复检，辩称证据没有被正确收集、测试或分析。他们的请求被警方拒绝，理由是样本已经用完，不再有效。审判在几个月内断断续续地进行，直到2015年12月24日宣判。受害者和被告的家人以及媒体成员聚集在法庭外，佐林和怀波戴着脚镣和橙色囚服被带入。被告的母亲从缅甸被带过来，当她们看到儿子时开始歇斯底里地哭泣。怀波的母亲恳求道，
Please release my son. My son did not do this. My son is not that kind of person. Please, I beg for justice. Inside, the judges declared Zorlin and Waipio guilty for all charges and sentenced both men to death. They were also ordered to pay David Miller's family for his stolen phone and return the murder weapon to its rightful owner. The mothers of the two men were led wailing from the courtroom. Hannah's family weren't present for the verdicts, but released a statement saying, The past year has served as an unimaginably impossible time for our family. We have found the trial process extremely difficult and our trips out to Thailand to attend court made for particularly distressing experiences. We found listening to proceedings very challenging and we have had to endure a lot of painful and confusing information.
“请释放我的儿子。我的儿子没有做这件事。我的儿子不是那种人。请，我恳求正义。”在法庭内，法官宣布佐林和怀波所有指控罪名成立，并判处两人死刑。他们还被勒令赔偿戴维·米勒家人被盗手机的费用，并将凶器归还给合法所有者。两名男子的母亲哭着被带离法庭。汉娜的家人没有出席判决，但发表声明说：“过去的一年对我们的家庭来说是难以想象的困难时期。我们发现审判过程极其困难，我们前往泰国参加法庭的行程造成了特别痛苦的经历。我们发现听取诉讼过程非常具有挑战性，我们不得不忍受很多痛苦和令人困惑的信息。”
We now need time as a family to digest the outcome of the trial and figure out the most appropriate way to tell our story. Outside court, David Miller's brother Michael told reporters, We believe the result today represents justice for David and Hannah. It is our opinion that the evidence against Waipio and Zorlin is absolutely overwhelming. They raped to satisfy their selfish desires and murdered to cover up that fact. They have shown no remorse during the trial. We believe that after a difficult start, the Royal Thai police conducted a methodical and thorough investigation. We hope the campaigners who have relentlessly promoted this case will respect the process of law and the decision of the court.
“我们现在需要时间作为家庭来消化审判结果，并找出讲述我们故事的最合适方式。”在法庭外，戴维·米勒的兄弟迈克尔告诉记者：“我们认为今天的结果代表了对戴维和汉娜的正义。我们认为针对怀波和佐林的证据绝对是压倒性的。他们为了满足自私的欲望而强奸，并为了掩盖这一事实而谋杀。他们在审判期间没有表现出任何悔意。我们相信，在经历了艰难的开端后，泰国皇家警察进行了有条不紊和彻底的调查。我们希望那些不懈推动此案的活动人士能够尊重法律程序和法院的决定。”
The verdict prompted widespread backlash, sparking protests on the Thailand-Myanmar border and the Thai Embassy in Myanmar in support of Zorlin and Waipio. The Thai government attempted to distance itself from the controversy, saying the accused had the right to appeal and that the verdict needed to be respected. From prison, Zorlin and Waipio released a statement that said, We are innocent and we are not involved in this horrific crime. We didn't kill. We want freedom. On January 3, support for the Burmese duo grew after a 37-minute long video appeared online from the international hacktivist group Anonymous. Known for orchestrating cyber attacks against the various government organizations and corporations, Anonymous had been conducting its own investigations into the allegations of police corruption in Thailand. Citing similar instances of wrongful convictions and bungled investigations, the group concluded that migrant workers were often scapegoated to ensure tourists weren't discouraged from visiting the country. A masked spokesman for Anonymous said,
这一判决引发了广泛的强烈反对，在泰国-缅甸边境和泰国驻缅甸大使馆引发了支持佐林和怀波的抗议活动。泰国政府试图与争议保持距离，称被告有权上诉，判决需要得到尊重。佐林和怀波从监狱发表声明说：“我们是无辜的，我们没有参与这起可怕的罪行。我们没有杀人。我们要自由。”1月3日，在国际黑客活动组织“匿名者”发布了一段37分钟的视频后，对这两名缅甸人的支持有所增加。以策划针对各种政府组织和公司的网络攻击而闻名的“匿名者”一直在对泰国警方腐败的指控进行自己的调查。引用类似的错误定罪和拙劣调查的案例，该组织得出结论，移民工人经常被当作替罪羊，以确保游客不会被劝阻而不到该国旅游。“匿名者”的一名蒙面发言人说，
We do not like the facts in this recent Qatar case and we do not believe that Thai court has convicted the actual murderers of this crime. Anonymous calls for this case to be re-investigated with credible forensic specialists. They also encouraged people to reconsider travelling to Thailand until Thai police improved the way they handled rape and murder cases involving foreigners and showed more respect for victims. In a bid to apply pressure to the authorities, Anonymous hacked into the websites of 14 Thai police organizations, replacing the website text with an image of the iconic anonymous mask along with the message Failed law. We want justice. Hashtag boycott Thailand. Days later, on Friday, January 8, 2016, a Qatar security guard was patrolling a Sairi beach resort when he found the body of 26-year-old British bricklayer Luke Miller floating at the bottom of a swimming pool. Luke had travelled to Thailand in late December with two friends and according to a post on his Facebook page, he had spent the past two weeks living the dream.
“我们不喜欢最近卡陶案件中的事实，我们不相信泰国法院已经定罪了这起罪行的真正凶手。”“匿名者”呼吁对该案件进行可信的法医专家重新调查。他们还鼓励人们重新考虑前往泰国旅行，直到泰国警方改善他们处理涉及外国人的强奸和谋杀案件的方式，并表现出对受害者更多的尊重。为了向当局施压，“匿名者”黑进了14个泰国警察组织的网站，将网站文本替换为标志性的匿名者面具图像以及“失败的法律。我们要正义。抵制泰国标签”的信息。几天后，即2016年1月8日星期五，一名卡陶保安在巡逻西里海滩度假村时，发现26岁的英国泥瓦匠卢克·米勒的尸体漂浮在游泳池底部。卢克在12月下旬与两个朋友前往泰国，根据他Facebook页面上的一篇帖子，他过去两周一直在“过着梦想中的生活”。
Police concluded that Luke was intoxicated when he decided to show off to a group of party-goers by jumping into the pool from the nearby DJ booth. He sustained a head injury in the process and drowned as a result. However, this explanation didn't seem to add up. If Luke had been showing off, why were there no witnesses to the incident and why had nobody called for help? Also, it would have been very out of character for Luke, who was known to be afraid of water. When Luke's travel companions went to identify his body, they noticed hand-shaped bruises on his arms. Rumours began to spread that Luke had been assaulted the night before his death and accusations of a cover-up immediately began circulating, adding further fuel to the controversial verdict in the Hannah Witheridge and David Miller case. Two days after Luke Miller's death, Hannah's sister Laura became incensed after someone she knew made a comment about Thailand being the most beautiful place in the world.
警方断定卢克在决定通过从附近的DJ台跳进游泳池向一群派对参与者炫耀时喝醉了。他在过程中头部受伤，并因此溺水身亡。然而，这种解释似乎站不住脚。如果卢克在炫耀，为什么没有目击者看到这一事件，为什么没有人呼吁求救？此外，对于以怕水而闻名的卢克来说，这非常不符合他的性格。当卢克的旅行同伴去辨认他的尸体时，他们注意到他手臂上有手掌形状的淤青。有传言开始流传，卢克在去世前一天晚上遭到袭击，掩盖真相的指控立即开始流传，这进一步加剧了汉娜·威瑟里奇和戴维·米勒案件中争议性判决的火药味。在卢克·米勒去世两天后，汉娜的姐姐劳拉在得知她认识的人评论说泰国是世界上最美丽的地方后，变得愤怒不已。
She made a scornful post on her Facebook page, remarking, Aesthetically on a postcard or photograph, maybe. However, I have to disagree. Lots of things look beautiful. You only have to consider a lion or tiger. Beautiful to look at, yes, but get too close and they will tear you apart and feed you to their young. My point being that aesthetic beauty can lure you into a very dangerous trap. Expressing her disappointment in the handling of her sister's murder investigation, Laura accused Thai police of being corrupt and covering up the killings. She claimed to have received death threats from Thai people and that Thai's had offered her family money to keep quiet about the murders. Laura's allegations made the news and in response, Thai authorities announced they were considering legal action against her. Later that year, Britain's Channel 4 released a documentary about the case titled Murder in Paradise.
她在Facebook页面上发表了一篇尖刻的帖子，评论道：“在明信片或照片上看起来或许很美。然而，我不得不表示反对。很多东西看起来都很美。你只需要看看狮子或老虎。看起来很美，是的，但如果靠得太近，它们会把你撕成碎片并喂给幼崽。我的意思是，审美上的美可能会诱使你陷入非常危险的陷阱。”劳拉在表达对妹妹谋杀案调查处理方式的不满时，指责泰国警方腐败并掩盖了杀人事件。她声称自己收到了泰国人的死亡威胁，并称泰国人曾向她的家人提供金钱，要求他们对谋杀案保持沉默。劳拉的指控上了新闻，作为回应，泰国当局宣布他们正在考虑对她采取法律行动。那年晚些时候，英国第四频道发布了一部关于此案的纪录片，名为《天堂谋杀案》。
The mayor of Kutau told the filmmakers, Foreigners who come to Thailand, they live the lifestyle they want to without realising it is not their country. They are not allowed to do as they wish. There is a difference between our culture and their culture. It all depends on fate. This string of suspicious deaths and disappearances hadn't gone unnoticed by the international press, who were soon dubbing Kutau, Death Island and warning travellers of the dangers that lurked on this so-called paradise. Online message boards and social media sites became peppered with people who shared their own horror stories about the island and some even speculated that a serial killer was on the loose on Kutau.
涛岛的市长告诉电影制作人：“来到泰国的外国人，他们过着自己想要的生活，却没意识到这不是他们的国家。他们不允许随心所欲。我们的文化和他们的文化是有区别的。这一切都取决于命运。”这一连串可疑的死亡和失踪事件并没有逃过国际媒体的注意，他们很快将涛岛称为“死亡岛”，并警告游客这个所谓的“天堂”中潜伏着危险。在线留言板和社交媒体网站上充斥着分享自己在岛上恐怖经历的人，有些人甚至推测涛岛上有一个连环杀手在逃。
Zor Lin and Waipio appealed their conviction and on March 1, 2017, the results were announced. The court determined that their trial had been adequate and reliable and therefore the guilty verdict and death sentence would be upheld. But Kutau was far from being out of the spotlight. 30-year-old Elise Durlamaine had spent two years backpacking around Asia and Australia when she called her mother on April 17, 2017 to say she was ready to return home to Belgium. Elise had been staying at a yoga and tantra retreat on Copenhagen and she booked a ferry to the mainland for April 19. From there she would continue on to Bangkok. However, when that day came, Elise unexpectedly disembarked from the ferry on Kutau.
佐林和温觉对他们的定罪提出上诉，2017年3月1日，结果公布。法院认定他们的审判是充分且可靠的，因此维持有罪判决和死刑。但涛岛远未脱离聚光灯。30岁的埃莉斯·杜尔马因在亚洲和澳大利亚背包旅行了两年，2017年4月17日，她打电话给母亲说她准备回比利时了。埃莉斯一直住在帕岸岛的一个瑜伽和坦陀罗静修处，她预订了4月19日前往大陆的渡轮。从那里她将继续前往曼谷。然而，当那一天到来时，埃莉斯意外地在涛岛下了渡轮。
She left her luggage on board, taking only a small backpack before checking into a budget hotel near the ferry terminal. For reasons unknown, she used a fake surname and refused to provide her passport number. On the evening of her arrival, Elise was forced to switch hotels when the bungalow she was staying in caught fire. She then walked two and a half kilometres through the jungle and checked into a hotel on Ternot Bay, where she booked another ticket to Bangkok due to depart on April 24. Elise never boarded the ferry. Several days after her arrival on Kutau, locals noticed that a monitor lizard was acting strangely. They followed it into the jungle and found Elise's decomposing remains ravaged by wildlife.
她把行李留在船上，只带了一个小背包，然后在渡轮码头附近的一家经济型酒店办理了入住。出于未知的原因，她使用了一个假姓氏，并拒绝提供护照号码。抵达当晚，埃莉斯所住的平房着火，她被迫更换酒店。随后，她穿过丛林走了两公里半，在坦诺特湾的一家酒店办理了入住，并预订了另一张定于4月24日出发前往曼谷的船票。埃莉斯从未登上那艘渡轮。在抵达涛岛几天后，当地人注意到一只巨蜥表现异常。他们跟着它进入丛林，发现了埃莉斯被野生动物啃食后的腐烂遗骸。
The police declared Elise's death a suicide, saying that she had hung herself from a tree. But Elise's mother said that her daughter showed no signs of suicidal thoughts and had been rational during their last conversation. Elise hadn't left a suicide note and it didn't make sense that she would bother to pay for a trip home if she never intended to take it. Unconfirmed reports speculated that Elise's body had been partially burned and that a gas can had been found near her remains. Police were accused of covering something up to avoid further damaging the island's reputation. Under mounting pressure, police were forced to reopen the investigation into Elise Durlemaine's death. But after re-examining the evidence, they came to the same conclusion that it was an open and shut case of suicide. For the families of these young people who lost their lives on Kutau, the answers given by Thai police have been completely unsatisfactory.
警方宣布埃莉斯的死是自杀，称她在一棵树上上吊自杀。但埃莉斯的母亲说，她的女儿没有任何自杀倾向的迹象，在他们最后一次谈话时表现得很理智。埃莉斯没有留下遗书，如果她没打算回家，花钱买回家的票也说不通。未经证实的报道推测，埃莉斯的尸体被部分烧毁，在她的遗骸附近发现了一个汽油罐。警方被指控掩盖事实，以避免进一步损害该岛的声誉。在巨大的压力下，警方被迫重新调查埃莉斯·杜尔马因的死因。但在重新审查证据后，他们得出了同样的结论，即这是一起毫无疑问的自杀案件。对于这些在涛岛失去生命的年轻人的家庭来说，泰国警方给出的答案完全不能令人满意。
Bearing together, they formed a support group called Grieving Together We Want Justice. Christina Anasli's father told The Samoy Times, When is the world going to wake up to the fact mongrels in Thailand are getting away with murdering our kids? While two innocent Burmese face losing their lives for murders I believe were committed by a Thai mafia thug, while the Thai police stand by and do nothing. The mother of Ben Harrington, the IT consultant who allegedly died from a motorcycle collision on Kutau, said, As long as I can breathe, I will keep trying to find answers. In late June of 2018, an 18-year-old British woman and her male friend were drinking in a bar on Siree Beach when they suddenly became woozy. They stumbled outside and passed out on the sand.
他们团结在一起，成立了一个名为“共同哀悼，我们要正义”的支持小组。克里斯蒂娜·安斯利的父亲告诉《苏梅时报》：“世界什么时候才能意识到，泰国的杂种们正在逍遥法外地谋杀我们的孩子？当两名无辜的缅甸人面临因我认为是泰国黑帮暴徒犯下的谋杀案而失去生命的危险时，泰国警方却袖手旁观，什么也不做。”本·哈林顿的母亲，那位据称在涛岛死于摩托车碰撞的IT顾问，说：“只要我还能呼吸，我就会一直努力寻找答案。”2018年6月下旬，一名18岁的英国女子和她的男性朋友在塞里海滩的一家酒吧喝酒时，突然感到头晕目眩。他们跌跌撞撞地走到外面，昏倒在沙滩上。
When the woman came too, her friend was gone and a stranger was hovering over her but quickly fled. Realising her underwear had been removed and her cash and credit cards were missing had dawned on the woman that she'd been drugged, robbed and raped. Terrified, she quickly left Kutau and reported the incident to police on neighbouring Kop Nyang. She even had a t-shirt that potentially contained the perpetrator's DNA. However, the officer allegedly refused to accept the rape report, nor did they offer any kind of medical assistance. The woman returned to the UK, where her concerned mother contacted Suzanne Buchanan, a British expert who ran the Samui Times online newspaper. Suzanne was a vocal supporter of Zorlin and Waipio and had widely reported on the suspicious deaths and alleged cover-ups occurring on Kutau. She'd recently moved back to the UK after fearing it was no longer safe for her to live in Thailand.
当这名女子醒来时，她的朋友不见了，一个陌生人正徘徊在她上方，但很快逃跑了。意识到自己的内衣被脱掉，现金和信用卡也不见了，这名女子意识到自己被下药、抢劫并强奸了。惊恐万分的她迅速离开涛岛，并向邻近帕岸岛的警方报告了这起事件。她甚至有一件可能含有肇事者DNA的T恤。然而，据称警官拒绝接受强奸报案，也没有提供任何医疗援助。这名女子回到英国，她焦急的母亲联系了苏珊·布坎南，一位经营《苏梅时报》在线报纸的英国专家。苏珊是佐林和温觉的公开支持者，并广泛报道了发生在涛岛的可疑死亡事件和所谓的掩盖行为。由于担心在泰国生活不再安全，她最近搬回了英国。
Suzanne broke the story about the alleged drugging and rape of the 18-year-old and in turn, the Thai police issued a warrant for her arrest on the grounds that she was publishing false information and misleading the public. Twelve other individuals who posted about the rape on social media were also arrested. The case gained the attention of the Human Rights Watch, who urged the Thai police to drop the charges and accused them of, quote, using computer-related crime charges against anyone who questions their shoddy investigation of the Kutau Island rape case. A spokesperson for the organisation said, the Thai police should recognise their reputation is better served by solving crimes than prosecuting their critics. Zorlin and Waipio were transferred to Bang Kwan Central Prison in Bangkok, which has earned a reputation as one of the harshest penitentiaries in the world. Speaking to a journalist for Bangkok News site, Karside English, Zorlin said that they were being treated well because other inmates and guards believed in their innocence.
苏珊披露了这名18岁少女被下药和强奸的报道，作为回应，泰国警方以她发布虚假信息和误导公众为由，对她发出了逮捕令。其他12名在社交媒体上发布有关强奸案消息的人也被逮捕。此案引起了人权观察组织的注意，他们敦促泰国警方撤销指控，并指责他们“利用计算机相关犯罪指控来对付任何质疑他们对涛岛强奸案草率调查的人”。该组织的一位发言人表示，泰国警方应该认识到，解决犯罪比起诉批评者更能维护他们的声誉。佐林和温觉被转移到曼谷的邦光中央监狱，该监狱以世界上最严酷的监狱之一而闻名。在接受曼谷新闻网站《椰子曼谷》记者的采访时，佐林说他们受到了很好的对待，因为其他囚犯和狱警相信他们是无辜的。
Expressing his gratitude for their supporters, he said, I miss home too much. Sometimes I go crazy. Why am I here? I think about that all the time. In August 2019, Thailand's Supreme Court reviewed their case and upheld the death sentence, marking an end to their appeals process. Their only remaining hope lay in a royal pardon. In Thailand, the king's birthday is considered a particularly auspicious occasion, and to celebrate, royal pardons are often granted to convicted criminals. The following year, July 28, 2020, was King Wahiralongorn's 68th birthday. To commemorate the event and illustrate the king's clemency, Zorlin and Waipio's death sentences were reduced to life imprisonment. Waipio's brother told reporters,
在表达对支持者的感激之情时，他说：“我太想家了。有时我会发疯。我为什么在这里？我一直在想这个问题。”2019年8月，泰国最高法院审查了他们的案件并维持了死刑判决，结束了他们的上诉程序。他们唯一的希望在于皇家赦免。在泰国，国王的生日被认为是一个特别吉祥的日子，为了庆祝，通常会给予罪犯皇家赦免。次年，即2020年7月28日，是哇集拉隆功国王的68岁生日。为了纪念这一事件并彰显国王的仁慈，佐林和温觉的死刑被减为终身监禁。温觉的兄弟告诉记者：
I can't find words to express how thankful we are. The truth about what happened to Hanna, David and the other tourists on Katow is a subject that will likely remain shrouded in mystery and hearsay. Speculation about cover-ups and corruption on Katow continues to run rife online, which the head of the island, Warapan Dolwichian, said has ruined his family's standing. After online sleuths blamed his son Numsad for the murders and accused his family of concealing the crimes, Warapan slammed the media for inaccurate reporting. He called the allegations baseless, saying the speculation had left his family in ruins. He told Khasad English, This is not how things should be. Imagine if you have a son. You will understand my pain. Australian lawyer Ian Yarwood runs a Facebook and YouTube account titled Katow Death Island.
“我无法用言语表达我们有多么感激。”关于汉娜、大卫和涛岛其他游客身上发生的事情的真相，很可能仍将笼罩在神秘和传闻之中。关于涛岛掩盖真相和腐败的猜测在网上继续泛滥，岛主瓦拉潘·多尔维奇安表示，这毁了他家庭的地位。在网络侦探指责他的儿子努姆萨德是谋杀案凶手并指控他的家人隐瞒罪行后，瓦拉潘抨击媒体报道不准确。他称这些指控毫无根据，并表示这些猜测让他的家庭陷入了崩溃。他告诉《椰子曼谷》：“事情不应该是这样的。想象一下如果你有一个儿子。你会理解我的痛苦。”澳大利亚律师伊恩·亚伍德经营着一个名为“涛岛死亡岛”的Facebook和YouTube账号。
He believes that as many as 21 foreigners have died under suspicious or avoidable circumstances on Katow since the year 2000 alone. He has been sharing the suspicious deaths and survival stories online to raise awareness, remarking, Both heaven and hell can be found on Katow, but the tourism industry only wants people to learn of the bright side. Days after Hannah and David were killed, an article by BBC's Southeast Asia correspondent Jonathan Head explored Katow's underbelly and questioned whether Thailand is a safe place to visit. He concluded, For the most part, yes, but do not be fooled by the smiles and the glossy posters put out by the tourism authority. The reality behind them is an unequal profit-driven economy, much of it illegal, and a police force which has shown time and again its incapacity for controlling crime. Despite all the negative publicity, tourists haven't been deterred from visiting Katow, which is now considered one of Thailand's most popular destinations.
他认为，仅自2000年以来，就有多达21名外国人在涛岛死于可疑或可避免的情况。他一直在网上分享这些可疑的死亡事件和幸存者的故事以提高人们的认识，并评论道：“涛岛上既有天堂也有地狱，但旅游业只想让人们了解光明的一面。”在汉娜和大卫被杀几天后，BBC东南亚记者乔纳森·黑德的一篇文章探讨了涛岛的阴暗面，并质疑泰国是否是一个安全的旅游地。他总结道：“在很大程度上，是的，但不要被旅游局发布的微笑和精美的海报所迷惑。它们背后的现实是一个不平等的、以利润为导向的经济，其中大部分是非法的，还有一个一次又一次证明其无力控制犯罪的警察部队。”尽管有所有负面宣传，但游客并没有被阻止访问涛岛，该岛现在被认为是泰国最受欢迎的目的地之一。
Westerners are advised to exercise common sense, respect the local culture, and avoid walking alone at night, just like they would anywhere else in the world. The vast majority of people who go there have an enjoyable, memorable holiday and remain blissfully unaware of the island's dark side. But for the families of Hannah Witheridge and David Miller, Katow will always be synonymous with death. Speaking outside the Trial of Zorlin and Waipio, David's brother Michael said, Weeks after Zorlin and Waipio's second appeal was rejected, tragedy struck the Witheridge family for a second time, when Hannah's 30-year-old sister Laura passed away suddenly from complications related to a rare nerve condition. She was nine weeks pregnant at the time. At a subsequent inquest, Hannah and Laura's mother wept as she said, You lose one daughter, you don't expect to lose another.
建议西方人运用常识，尊重当地文化，避免晚上独自外出，就像在世界任何其他地方一样。绝大多数去那里的人都度过了一个愉快、难忘的假期，并且对该岛的阴暗面一无所知。但对于汉娜·威瑟里奇和大卫·米勒的家人来说，涛岛将永远是死亡的代名词。在大卫的兄弟迈克尔在佐林和温觉的审判外发言时，他说：“在佐林和温觉的第二次上诉被驳回几周后，悲剧第二次降临到威瑟里奇家族，汉娜30岁的姐姐劳拉因一种罕见神经疾病的并发症突然去世。她当时怀孕九周。”在随后的死因裁判官调查中，汉娜和劳拉的母亲哭着说：“失去一个女儿，你没想到会失去另一个。”
Hannah will always be remembered by her loved ones as an intelligent and loving young woman who poured joy into the lives of all who knew her. Speaking of the grief she endured after the murders, Hannah's mother said, There wasn't a bad bone in Hannah's body. She achieved so much and had so much more ahead of her. Our family is broken and will never be the same again. It will never make any sense. The fact that she is not here affects us every day. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
汉娜将被她的亲人永远铭记为一个聪明、充满爱心的年轻女性，她为所有认识她的人的生活带来了欢乐。在谈到谋杀案后她所承受的悲痛时，汉娜的母亲说：“汉娜身上没有一点坏心眼。她取得了这么多成就，未来还有更多。我们的家庭破碎了，再也不会和以前一样了。这永远说不通。她不在了的事实每天都在影响着我们。”感谢观看。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。